Bienvenue à la représentation finale du
Championnat du monde de Brain Games, nous serons
rejoint en un instant par le nouveau monde
Champion j'aimerais l'inviter sur scène
Maintenant, ayons une grosse main pour le 14
Champion du Monde Vainqueur du
braingames.net Championnat du monde d'échecs
Vladimir
[applaudissements]
Kramnick
nous allons juste prendre quelques photos
avant de commencer pour notre propre personnel
archives UM nous laisserons le monde UH
La presse prend quelques photos du monde
Champion pour commencer J'aimerais
invitez M. AD Luan sur scène. Qui est le
Inspiration derrière la collecte de fonds pour
L'événement Je voudrais une grosse main pour Monsieur
Sans quoi cela n'aurait pas été possible
[applaudissements]
c'est arrivé alors s'il te plaît, prends autant de photos
comme tu veux, viens et tiens-toi devant, près
notre logo vladimir pour que les gens puissent voir le
Le bit des jeux de réflexion Juste Juste Ne fais pas juste
Juste ici, c'est parfait Oui Merci
tu Quand tu as eu autant de photos que
vous avez besoin du champion du monde, nous le ferons
nous allons venir chercher notre officiel
photo pour nous
archives Qu'attendez-vous, nous aurons notre
photographier D'accord, pouvons-nous, nous pouvons, nous allons
tout corbeau
autour oui
oui Allan Viens rejoindre le
groupsut Merci beaucoup en effet
Merci
tu vas bien maintenant, euh, comme vous le voyez probablement, nous
avoir le grand maître Danny King sur scène
[applaudissements]
ni même s'il est un très bon joueur, il
pas Gary Kasparov et donc il ne le sera pas
jouer aux échecs contre Vladimir Kamam
Aujourd'hui, un peu de ce qui se passe
ce qui va arriver Aujourd'hui, nous allons commencer
je vais commencer en regardant deux
Des jeux qui ont connu des moments critiques
Cela pourrait affecter The Match et Danny et
Vladimir va fournir aux États-Unis
un aperçu de ces moments critiques
UM Après cela, nous vous présenterons
Kramnick en jetant un oeil à son
carrière à certains de ses meilleurs et des plus flashy
jeux, nous allons répondre à quelques questions
du public et euh certains ont préparé
des questions et nous prendrons des pauses UH
Toutes les heures environ pour que tu puisses respirer
profondément et étirez vos jambes et ainsi
ce sera une réunion assez informelle
affaire donc sans plus tarder j'aimerais
passer la parole à Danny King et Danny et
Vladimir va commencer à jeter un œil au
moments clés de ce match
avec numéro de jeu
ce vieux truc qui le fait tourner
je ne pense pas que ce soit Ah
Ouais, et bien, toutes mes félicitations, Vladimir
Performance fantastique UM, cela semblait
Les États-Unis dans la boîte de commentaires pour être purs
Stratégie antikasparov dès le
mot va fouetter les reines, amortir le
Play Down Out jouer, c'est à peu près ça
ta stratégie ouais tu as exactement raison
c'était exactement ma stratégie et bien, je
cours que je préparais très sérieusement
pour le match et moi
que bien tu peux jouer aussi contre
lui mais je suis plutôt un joueur universel et
donc je peux aussi jouer de manière très agressive mais je
je le connais très bien et je pense que je me sens
Je le sens très bien, je ressens quel genre de
postes qu'il aime, quel genre de fait
j'ai aimé et puis j'ai décidé
aller chercher Thisaty Queens dès que
possible et euh je dirais que c'est un peu
défensive
Stratégie correcte Parce que je me souviens de l'UM dans
une interview quelques mois avant The
Match que vous avez mentionné, on vous a demandé
savoir quelles sont les faiblesses de Scubov et
tu n'as mentionné qu'une chose que tu as dite
Eh bien, c'est bien connu, ce gparov
Aime jouer incroyablement activement et
Parfois dans certaines positions et bien toi
je ne peux pas toujours faire ça, je veux dire.
identifier les autres faiblesses qu'Il a
surtout après ce match
[musique]
Eh bien mai pour compliquer le grand public
Parce que je dois les résoudre
mais bon, je pense que le principal, je pense
son M Dans ce match, ce match s'est-il déroulé
direction complètement différente de celle qu'il
je m'attendais à ce que ce soit un gros problème parce que
Je pense qu'il en avait définitivement
attente Direction j'ai réussi je veux dire je
le surprend beaucoup avec cette stratégie
jouer à cette fin de partie avec Black et le
Stratégie à laquelle il ne s'attendait pas et puis il
je ne savais pas quoi faire en fait, je veux dire
pour le dire avec des mots qu'il ne savait pas quoi
faire et il
n'était pas là, il ne pouvait pas montrer son meilleur
aux échecs, je veux dire, il a dit après ça
tu l'as complètement surpassé mais je
veut dire sûrement Un Pour pouvoir improviser
tu sais à un moment donné je me suis demandé pourquoi
n'a-t-il pas protégé son EP quand tu
attaqué
il n'était pas obligé d'entrer dans cette fin
Il a joué le jeu UH Ouais, il n'en avait pas ouais
Ouais, bien, UH, c'était aussi assez étrange
pour moi Parce que UH Eh bien, le Blanc a un Blanc
Choice White peut opter pour D4 Play Scotch
et jouer d'autres choses Sharp mais
il y allait tout le temps pour ça, je
Je pense que c'était probablement une question de
principe pour lui parce qu'il a vu bien dans
fait bien sûr The End Game
c'est légèrement mieux pour les blancs, je veux dire
Les blancs ont de la pression et je pense que c'était un
Question de principe parce qu'il, je suis le
Champion et je suis le meilleur joueur et je
Je ne peux pas gagner une meilleure fin de partie, je veux dire une fois
deux fois, troisième fois, et bien, je veux, je veux
Poussez et essayez de gagner un jeu dans ce
Terminer le jeu pour montrer que je ne peux pas seulement
Attaque mais je peux aussi jouer très
Des échecs techniques très positionnels mais il
je n'ai finalement pas pu le faire mais je
je pense que c'était une question de principe parce que
normalement je pense que si pendant que tu joues
variation et tu ne comprends pas vraiment
n'obtiens rien avec ça, tu essaies de changer
Je suis juste très inquiet que tout le monde le soit
maintenant je vais jouer au Berlin
Défense quoi qu'il en soit Continuons et regardons
Jeu 14 Ce qui est vraiment un
Moment critique du match si vous
J'ai perdu ce jeu UM aurait pu être un
une fin différente, euh, et bien, je dirais
les choses seraient plus difficiles ouais ouais
absolument
Hum, tu m'avais l'air de jouer un
un peu nerveux ces derniers temps
Jeux That's That bien sûr mais aussi
Mon niveau descend un peu à la fin
mais c'est normal parce que bon, quand
Le but est si proche et euh tu viens
je dois faire quelques tirages et
tout se passe bien mais toujours bien sûr
Au fond de ton esprit, tu as juste peur
Faire quelque chose de mal, quelque chose de vraiment
Stupide, je veux dire, je dirais parce que ok
Eh bien, nous sommes tous les deux déjà fatigués et quand
Tu es fatigué, tu peux faire une sorte de
erreur que vous ne faites jamais vraiment et
ça m'a rendu un peu nerveux alors bien sûr
Quand j'ai joué à ce jeu 14, ouais, c'était
pas mon meilleur jeu je dirais dans mon
la vie Ok, eh bien, jetons un coup d'oeil à cela
veux-tu nous parler, ok, j'y suis allé
Knight F3 pour la première fois dans ce
Match UH Juste pour bien, mon idée n'était pas
Juste pour venir ici et faire un tirage au sort, je veux dire
J'ai réalisé que ce n'était pas la bonne stratégie
Général pour essayer de faire match nul même si
tu en as besoin tu as besoin Juste pour jouer normalement
aux échecs mais ok F3 est le coup que je
je joue assez souvent aussi et je voulais juste
jouer un peu plus, un peu plus en sécurité que
habituel mais c'est quand même pour jouer, je veux dire, c'était
ce n'est pas mon intention de faire un tirage au sort
commençant donc Knight F6 C C4 B6 UH Eh bien, je
veux dire Une autre preuve ici que si je le voulais
j'aime vraiment faire un tirage au sort immédiatement
dès le début, j'irais D4 ici
Ce qui est très sûr mais j'ai juste décidé de
je joue au G3 comme je le fais habituellement
jouer J'ai déjà eu plusieurs jeux comme
ceci donc C5 Bishop G2 Bishop B7
Château G6 Chevalier C3 Fou G7 D4 C prend
D4 Queen prend D4 Et bien, je n'explique pas
c'est surtout parce que c'est une théorie de base donc
Je veux dire, il y a aussi plein de jeux
signifie que c'est un système que Kasparov a
joué pas mal de fois avec les noirs
morceaux Ouais je pense que The Since
1984 Contre ouais UM alors ok tu le ferais
préparé ceci, vous deviez vous y attendre
tu as joué tes Moves très rapidement UH
Bien sûr, j'ai aussi eu quelques jeux
en fait dans ce système mais bon c'est
il suffit de positionner qu'il y a des lignes No Force donc
Il n'est pas nécessaire de se préparer sérieusement
pour ça, tu as juste besoin d'y jouer. Eh bien, je
ça veut dire que c'est blanc, c'est très légèrement mieux
mais les Noirs ont une configuration Solide et UH a
quelques contre-chances donc juste un
jeu de position
Ici, alors qu'est-ce que c'était D6
Je ouais ouais
D17 Fou E3 tour c8 Ce sont tous
mouvements normaux1 je veux dire des deux côtés Essayez de
Terminer le développement des châteaux Queen H4
A6 Ouais, c'est bien l'un des points critiques
positions dans cette ouverture et normalement je
signifie que les Blancs jouent B3 en fait. C'est le
façon et j'avais ce poste avec les deux
Les couleurs déjà j'y ai joué avec le noir
et je l'ai joué avec les Blancs avec les deux
Les couleurs et je l'ai joué, je
je pense qu'il y a un an environ Il y a un an
contrepov dans le tournoi inas et je suis allé
B3 Ici, ce qui est un mouvement normal et ensuite
il a fait le meilleur coup du poste
C'est en fait que je peux dire un truc drôle
Histoire à ce sujet
Parce que nous avons eu un tournoi Blitz
comme il y a un an et demi et UH dans le
Au premier tour, j'ai joué contre toi
jouez simplement à un système qui peut-être
normalement, je ne joue pas et puis c'est toi
theard et dans le mouvement thétique, c'est la tour
mouvement principal mais je confonds simplement le
bouge F parce que le point est cette tour8
puis Next suivi de la tour C7 et
reine A8 ce genre de configuration et je Simplement
j'ai confondu le mouvement et je suis devenu la tour C7 et
Il semblait en fait très fort
nouveauté C'était une nouveauté à cette époque
et puis Après ce jeu Après ce jeu
C'était sur Internet je pense et tout le monde
Je l'ai vu et tout le monde a commencé à jouer
tour C7 et en fait Carp a joué contre
moi et cela semblait être vraiment le
coup le plus fort dans la position C'était
assez drôle parce que je suis simplement confus
le mouvement ok les meilleures inventions ouais
et pourquoi B3 tour C7 C'est comme ça
Anatoly Carpov a joué contre moi donc le
L'idée avec la tour C7 est de mettre la Dame dedans
le coin ouais et puis mettre la tour
de f8 à c8 et Black Start certains
Jeu de contre-jeu du côté de la reine
B5 un peu de Point tu G un gros Tempo ça
il n'est pas nécessaire d'aller à re8 d'abord, et bien le
Le fait est que, bien sûr, la recrue 8
Le but de la tour 8 est d'éviter le changement
c'est perdre de la température avec la tour de toute façon
dans mon jeu avec Scarp, je suis passé au G4.
position très agressive Move et c'était
un jeu très pointu très intéressant et
finalement c'était un
dessiner mais après le match, je viens d'avoir
Eh bien, j'ai juste eu une idée ici pour
play1 mais bon, ce n'était pas génial. C'était
brillant
et pendant le jeu, je
Laissez simplement TR fonctionner parce que c'est un nouveau mouvement
et bien c'est normal bouge mais en fait
probablement B3 routine théorique normale
c'est mieux je dois dire que 91 c'est pas très
chanceux
Move Well L'idée que les Noirs sont en quelque sorte
doit prendre Bishop G2 G2 et White Idea
c'est maintenant d'amener kight en d5 normalement pour
repartir avec un Fou en G5 ou H6 puis
et serol sur le Centre C'est pourquoi je
je n'aime pas jouer au système avec les noirs
Je pense toujours que cette place est pour nous
d5 mais là je dirais que My My
les pièces ne sont pas très bien coordonnées Mon
Queen sur H est un peu hors jeu, je le ferais
dit et les Noirs parviennent à devenir très bons
la position parvient en fait à obtenir légèrement
Très vite, la tour est dans une meilleure position
un très bon coup, un très bon coup parce que
Eh bien, le fait est qu'il faut transférer
sa reine à
et s'il part immédiatement7 alors d5 est très
désagréable et après K prend d5 C prend d5
Le problème c'est la Reine si la Reine s'en va
à B7 Le pa s'accroche7 et donc Ceci
est une tour de mouvement prophylactique très profonde
Ce n'est pas vraiment contre Bish H6 mais c'est
je protège juste le on7 pour cette ligne
et UH Eh bien, je dois admettre qu'ici, je
réel que mon idée originale ne fonctionne pas
efficace Parce que bien sûr je pense
à propos de ce déménagement mais mon idée originale était
jouer à Bishop G5, je veux dire, juste pour y aller
ce plan kn3 d5 et ne perdez pas de température pour
B3, c'est en fait pourquoi je suis devenu kn1
sinon bien sur je commencerais par
B3 donc l'idée n'était pas de perdre
Temp avec B3 mais ensuite j'ai réalisé que
Les noirs ont une manœuvre très forte, je n'en ai pas.
Je sais si mon adversaire l'a vu, je suppose
tour très masculine
C5 et UH Maintenant, assez étrangement, After Let
disons que 3 H6 est une menace à cause de
b prend h h prend et ce n'est pas le mien
l'intention d'abandonner ce souhait pour cela
Ce n'est pas pour ça que je suis allé au Bishop G5 donc le
Le mouvement normal est B4 ici juste pour essayer de
Attaque La tour mais ensuite la tour Va en E5
Ce qui n'est pas normal pour cette Ligne mais
se tient assez bien sur normalement la tour F5
bien sûr
mais cette tour a été vue pour Swing
à travers The Four R en fait aussi
conscient
et F4 par exemple
tour Eh bien, la tour semble être très
vulnérable sur Six mais en fait en fait
les blancs ont des problèmes, le carré est très faible
Kin n'est pas génial, il est hors jeu et je
je pense que le noir est tout simplement meilleur ici
C'est un problème. Le noir est tout simplement meilleur.
Pourquoi, et bien, j'ai dû changer mes plans que j'avais
pour jouer à B3 c'est allumé c j'ai dû jouer à B3 mais
puis j'ai réalisé que bien sûr je l'avais fait
quelque chose ne va pas parce qu'alors c'est là
No Sense jouait-il à 1 ? J'étais un peu contrarié.
avec ça parce que ce n'était tout simplement pas le cas
très intelligent ce que j'ai fait mais ok quand même il
je suis devenu Queen C7, je pense, ce qui est un bon
Bouge et maintenant UH Here After
certains je ne sais pas 10 minutes ou je
réalise qu'en fait, je suis pire, ici, mon
la situation est légèrement pire, encore pire
déjà un peu pire Oui
Parce qu'il a un plan très clair pour bouger
Queen sur B7 et joue à B5 en organisant
contre-attaque très désagréable sur la Reine
Côté et UH, je n'ai aucun plan
fait parce que et désolé, excusez-moi, je pourrais
vous expliquez simplement pourquoi ce plan avec
jouer B5 est si bon pour que les noirs obtiennent
dans Eh bien, le fait est que les Noirs ont besoin
pour organiser du Counter play et aussi
doit obtenir le contrôle sur la case d5.
imaginons que Blanc joue Kin H1 Kin
G1 donc les Noirs jouent la Reine B7 puis les Noirs
joue B5 Ensuite, est-ce réellement sur le
tableau c'est sur le tableau
et maintenant la question est Comment réagir Comment
pour réagir, Eh bien, les Blancs en ont Deux
Ways One Way est de prendre B5 et
Une autre façon est de le garder comme ça.
si les Blancs prennent B5 alors Après a prend
B5 UH Les Blancs perdent le contrôle sur la case d5
Quel est le principal carré critique pour
cette position aussi les Noirs deviennent très
contre-jeu désagréable sur la C Line et
Imaginons et Noir commence à construire
le Centre plus tard en jouant avant Let's
disons Kicks this Night Out par exemple
Ouais, juste une idée de base et puis
Noir commence à jouer d5 E5 et Noir est
Tout simplement beaucoup mieux, je veux dire, ok, c'est
certes très provisoire mais extra
Centre C'est la chose la plus importante
C'est la chose importante et si je si
Je continue comme ça et Black prend le dessus
C4 et Après B prend C4 Mon sur C4 devient
très faible et les Noirs commencent à attaquer
ce papa joue 5, je ne sais pas doubler
tours sur C L et j'ai Super
difficultés Simplement pour défendre le pion
Ok, et bien, c'est à peu près ce qui s'est passé dans
le jeu Voyons ça, je ne pouvais pas
Arrête ça quand même, Reine
C7 maintenant bien
probablement euh, j'ai fait un autre affront
anacuracy Dans cette position comme c'était le cas
mentionné plus tard par mon deuxième
M Bishop H6 était plus fort que Bish
que Bishop G5 Bien sûr, je suis ce Mo
et je bouge, c'est légèrement
meilleur bish prend que la reine prend
H Queen B7 essayant de B5 et maintenant j'ai
Well My Queen sur H6 n'est pas si bon
étrangement, parce que toutes sortes de
les attaques d'accouplement ne fonctionnent pas Black Knight
peut aller en f8 pour défendre UH the Kin et
Il n'y a aucun moyen de rompre ici donc j'ai besoin
me retirer avec ma reine pour
D2 B5 et puis puis kn3 essayant Après
B tak4 à prendre avec un kight sur C4 et
Eh bien, je dirais que les blancs sont presque égaux
C'est mai très légèrement mieux pour mais
Rien de très grave, je veux dire, c'est le
la façon dont je devrais jouer, bien sûr, je le fais
mais Bishop G5 est
d'une manière ou d'une autre, UH, c'est beaucoup plus intéressant
Parce que ça fait aussi
noir noir Jouer pas aussi facilement qu'après
Bishop H6 alors j'ai décidé d'aller à Bishop
Bishop G5 enfin ouais Queen
b73 mouvements normaux malheureusement je ne peux pas
Empêche vraiment les Noirs de jouer B5 pendant
inst comme ça A4 Parce que Knight C5 et
alors B3 est Nous et c'est très difficile de
Protège ça et bien toutes ces choses sont
ça se passe parce que ma reine n'est plus là
du jeu malheureusement donc je dois y aller
chevalier3
B5 Ouais, bien, nous UH, nous réfléchissons à un
ça fait longtemps que nous sommes tous les deux à chaque mouvement
Parce que euh, bizarrement, la position
est très difficile à jouer pour les deux
Couleurs pour les deux côtés maintenant j'avais un
Choix général entre jouer kn ed5 ou
Knight CD5, je veux dire, c'est clair, j'en ai besoin
mettre mon chevalier en d5 mais lequel lequel
Un ceci est une question et
UH Peut-être que c'était mieux de jouer au chevalier
C d5 Peut-être que c'était mieux donc je veux dire
Après avoir joué à ça, tu étais
aux prises avec ce por isolé ouais UM je
ça veut dire que nous envisageions principalement kn cd5
bien sûr, juste pourquoi, pourquoi tu ne voulais pas
pour le faire, continuez. Eh bien, le problème est que
Que j'ai commencé à penser
et bien, juste une idée pour moi que si nous allons
Dis si Noir dit comme dans un jeu de cartes
Quelle est la prochaine étape, c'est très difficile de
trouvez le prochain coup pour les Blancs ici
Parce que My Knight on3 est très passif
d'une manière ou d'une autre, c'est bien mieux de l'avoir sur soi
C3 plus Peut-être parfois Parfois tu sais UH
et bizarrement tu connais le mouvement
ce que je n'ai pas aimé Après kn C d5 est
A5 C'est pourquoi je ne voulais pas vraiment
jouer C d5
À cause d'un étrange mouvement A5 et maintenant je
je ne vois pas de mouvement pour les blancs. Simplement, je
je ne vois pas d'utilité Déplacer Le fait est que je peux
expliquer Peut-être que c'est un peu trop compliqué
mais quoi qu'il en soit, le problème est que si les Noirs essaient
Exchange sur C4 immédiatement puis Après
la tour prend C4, je suis juste à temps pour
organiser la tour Counter Play prend C4 Queen
prend C4 H6 C'est un Move Knight normal
prend F6 kn prend
F6 Bishop prend F6 Je dois abandonner mon
Bishop parce que sinon bish s'en va
à F4 H4 G5 je le perds donc Bishop
prend F6 L'évêque prend F6 Chevalier d5
Bishop G7 et maintenant si les Noirs sont dans le Temps de
jouer E6 tour c8 je veux dire, je vais devoir le faire
je souffre pour un match nul mais voilà, j'ai ça
ressource Reine C7 C'est un élément très important
Déplacez-vous parce qu'après que la reine prenne 7, il y a
pas d'autre moyen, K prend 7, je prends le papa
il
A6
ceci parce que
Toujours après avoir joué un After A5 White
ça n'a pas d'utilité, je pensais
Je vais devoir faire quelques mouvements comme
Queen F4 Quoi qu'il en soit, puis Black opte pour
ceci pour cette ligne prenant C4 tout ça
Ligne puis Le pa est protégé
Ouais, nous n'avons pas repéré
ça et bien de toute façon, peut-être que c'était mieux
jouer comme ça parce qu'After Night 5
Euh b tak4 b tak
C4 UH C'est un peu réciproque, je veux dire, c'est
très difficile de trouver le coup pour Boss
en fait, les Noirs sont également liés à leur
morceaux Parce que E7 pa c'est Nous, il ne peut pas
bouge-le kn est accroché à F6 et et
Il n'y a aucun moyen d'attaquer le pa
immédiatement mais After Deep est mon adversaire
J'ai trouvé ce très Strong Move H5 en fait
en d'autres termes, il a juste dit et puis il
m'a donné le choix et je pense
Ici, c'était assez drôle parce que je
J'ai commencé à regarder la position. Eh bien,
ce n'était pas si drôle pendant le match
Mais j'ai commencé à regarder la position
et c'est incroyable parce que toutes les pièces sont
sur le tableau mais en fait UH ce n'est pas le cas
à propos de ça, les Blancs n'ont pas d'utilité
Bougez mais en fait, chaque mouvement est blanc
fait que c'est UH Wors dans sa position vous
je sais que c'est incroyable, ouais, je
je n'ai pas trouvé, je le ferais, si je pouvais
dire je dirais Passe ici Non, je ne le fais pas
se déplacer
normalement ça se passe en endames dans
endames avec très peu de morceaux au dos
mais toutes les pièces sur le plateau sont toujours
Ayez un peu de mouvement qui améliore le
position mais c'est
C'est tout simplement un cas incroyable pour la première fois
dans ma vie, j'ai une telle position où
J'ai toutes mes pièces et je n'en ai pas
Mouvement utile et chaque mouvement
aggrave Ma situation Parce que par exemple
Je pensais à un Move comme A3
mais c'est une mauvaise façon de dire parce que
puis la Reine B3 arrive et puis My are
Sous attaque, ok, laissez-moi essayer et
Bougez juste pour le plaisir, laissez-moi vous laisser
j'essaye H3 ouais H3 H3 c'est possible mais
Je crois quand même qu'un peu de faiblesse
Ouais, c'est une petite faiblesse, ouais et
Parfois, ma reine doit aller au H3 G2
Parfois et Après H3 par exemple dans
certaines lignes My My Queen peuvent rester piégées
Parce qu'il n'y a pas ce Square sur H3
Eh bien, mais le problème est que si je vais au H3
il peut en trouver
A5 Un autre mouvement et bien de toute façon c'est ainsi
donc finalement, je n'ai pas beaucoup aimé
mais je devais aller au Queen F4 parce que je
je ne veux pas changer Mon kn sur F6 en
changer cette paire de kns Parce qu'alors je
veux dire alors ce que je fais je veux dire je je je
dépenser tellement d'énergie en mettant My sur d5
et puis juste pour le changer moi-même
C'est le seul mouvement utile que j'ai trouvé
Le problème de ce mouvement est qu'alors
Je n'ai pas une telle pression sur
E7 pa donc dans certains
Les lignes UH Black peuvent en profiter et
maintenant
mon Dieu je je
je pense qu'en fait, je ne sais même pas si
il attaque le pion sur C4, ce n'est pas clair
pour moi ouais, au fait, un intéressant
variation Voici ça UH Eh bien, c'est ça
ce serait génial d'attaquer sa reine
jouer la tour B1, la dame C6 et la tour dc1
Eh bien maintenant, le point est que disons si
J'y retourne maintenant, je ne pense pas que noir soit noir
peut prendre C4, je n'étais pas sûr pendant le
jeu Parce qu'After Queen prend C4 UH I
avoir une astuce tactique que prend7 Check
la tour prend E7 kn
d5 c'est une bonne tactique et je pense que UH End
Avec du matériel supplémentaire donc après la reine
prends ouais, je prends E7 ou C8 avec Check
Disons que kn prend E7 Check et UH King
H7 puis je prends H4 et Exchange Up
donc c'est un point mais
Reine C tour dc1 ce que je veux réellement
jouer Parce qu'alors je n'ai pas vraiment besoin
myook mais B F est très important donc ça
J'adorerais faire cet ensemble mais ensuite je
avait peur de pouvoir déjà prendre et après
kn prend E7 La tour check prend
E7 Dans cette position, je prends, je sais
prendre C7 Vérifier le mouvement intermédiaire et l'entrée
cette position, la tour en prend une, disons que je
prendre avec Une tour la tour prend Un Chèque
Bishop prend C1 et maintenant Knight prend d5
protéger la tour sur E7 et UH Well
le noir le noir est meilleur simplement ici deux
Ouais, une tour et deux KS Queen
Oui
alors ok, de toute façon, alors pourquoi finalement je
je suis devenu Queen F mais je veux dire toutes ces lignes
Bien sûr, cela prend du temps, c'est pourquoi nous sommes arrivés
dans Time Trouble, en fait, c'est moi qui m'aime
Parce qu'il faut
Time Queen F4 Queen C6 et maintenant encore I
je veux dire, je ne sais pas si Queen prend 4 est un
mais je veux dire, j'ai des problèmes
avec moov donc j'ai décidé Eh bien, c'est ça
juste le temps de simplifier la position a
peu que j'ai pris sur F6 kn prend F6 Bishop
prend F6 Fou prend F6 Chevalier d5 Nous nous
nous nous posions des questions sur Knight E4
si
que d5 Parce que joue le malheur il
joue Bishop
et The End Game est vraiment
difficile et c'est pourquoi je suis allé en d5
Parce que bien, juste général, je peux
Organisez des contre-attaques sur le
K, ce que j'ai finalement réussi à faire
et je pense qu'il a fait une erreur. Ici, il a fait
une brume sérieuse
bisou
B2 Je pense que c'était bien mieux d'y aller, bisous
G7 Simply and Well Black est légèrement
mieux après Queen G5 pour une attaque instantanée
le pa7, ce n'est pas facile de bien le protéger
Parce que par exemple maintenant, si Noir essaie
pour protéger comme ça Kin F puis My Idea
c'était pour commencer un contre-jeu avec la tour
D3 tour F3 attaquant pa sur G6 et Blanc
a un contrepoint vraiment sérieux sur le K
C'est peut-être le seul moyen de se protéger
le pa doit jouer la reine B7 maintenant si la tour
B1 puis Reine
A7 et
UH Eh bien, je crois que Black est toujours
un peu mieux, je veux dire, je dois je dois
jouer très prudemment pour faire match nul
Ici parce qu'il a réussi à se défendre
tout et puis lentement il commence à
Attaquez le C4 donc c'était bien mieux
façon de jouer et j'ai été assez surpris par
ce Move Bishop B2 Parce que c'est alors je je
je suis dans le temps de mettre ma tour sur B1 je veux dire
il moi, il me donne simplement une température supplémentaire pour
Peu de raisons pour lesquelles Bishop G7, je pense que je
[musique]
G que G G5 Ouais f8 Maintenant, il n'y a pas de reine
B7 C'est un point donc il ne peut pas le faire.
pa right kein F Eh bien mais maintenant
malheureusement, je ne peux pas y aller
Attaque parce que le père s'accroche alors je
je dois passer du temps à défendre cette pa
tour
DC Eh bien, j'étais déjà assez optimiste
à propos de ma position Eh bien, parce que j'ai
le dossier B et il est un peu attaché
Toujours avec le pa on7 et je pensais que j'étais
ça va déjà plus ou moins bien mais le
égalité des chances ou quelque chose comme ça. Eh bien, peut-être
Il est légèrement meilleur, encore légèrement
Mieux mais pas ce genre d'avantage
dont j'ai peur, tu le sais, je, je
j'arriverais à le tenir d'une manière ou d'une autre mais ensuite
Le problème était avec le temps, j'ai commencé à
faire quelques erreurs à ce moment-là
Des problèmes alors il est allé E6. Et bien parce que
sinon difficile de trouver un outil utile
bouge bien sûr. C'est une sorte de
consolation, je veux dire jouer à E6 parce qu'il
donne-moi ce F6 Square Ce n'est pas trop
c'est bien de le faire mais peut-être qu'il n'y en a pas
Autre choix déjà Chevalier F6 tour E d8
UH Eh bien, maintenant j'ai trouvé un très bon coup, je
crois très bon Move et UH mais The
le problème, c'est que je me suis simplement détendu après
ce mouvement je l'ai tellement aimé que je me suis détendu
et j'ai dit Okay, maintenant je ne suis pas pire du tout
et UH, il était trop tôt pour se détendre, je pense
H4 est un mouvement très fort parce que je veux dire que nous
étions-nous perplexes face à celui-là ?
je dois admettre que le fait est que
L'idée des noirs est de jouer la reine C5.
au prochain coup et ensuite s'il est homme
j'ai réussi à changer les reines normalement
situation alors il va mieux donc le point
du coup H4 est d'avoir Après la Reine C5
tour B7 pour protéger la Reine en fait
la tour B7 et maintenant la tour entre sur le S
classer un contre-jeu immédiat ouais
Queen prend G5 H prend G5 et maintenant j'obtiens
K très fort
donc et ma tour est au rang S et
Il n'y a aucun moyen de l'expulser du
S R et White ne sont au moins pas pires ici
donc c'était un point du mouvement H4
justilactique
en fait
mais ou sa prochaine reine
En effet, si tu avais réellement oublié cela
ou non. J'ai vu cette possibilité mais je
je n'ai pas fait trop attention j'étais
principalement en calculant parce que vous connaissez le
Le fait est que quand tu as Quand
À court de temps, normalement, vous calculez
quelques variations qui sont forcées et
alors ok tu penses que s'il joue un peu
comme la reine alors tu penseras parce que
Il n'y a rien de force après Queen mais
bien sûr, j'ai passé tout mon temps
calculer les complications UH qui AR
Après Queen C5 et ensuite Quand il est parti
La reine a dit : Laisse-moi et moi, ce n'est vraiment pas le cas
souvent, la menace est bien sûr la tour C5
Ouais, la tour C5 l'est et la reine a
défendu les tours donc il n'y a pas
trucs Ouais et UH Eh bien, bien sûr, je peux
Je peux y retourner avec tous mes morceaux en train de jouer
comme Reine F4 tour C5 Chevalier E4 mais ensuite
tour F5 et encore une fois sa tour commence à
joue au cinquième rang et toutes mes pièces
j'y retourne et je dois jouer à Queen et
Peut-être qu'en fait, je devrais peut-être entrer
fait Aller ailleurs H7 G5 mais noir
c'est mieux, je veux le dire en un mot
Le noir est meilleur donc je pense avoir trouvé un
très bonne façon de jouer, je suis passé au C5
Quand tu as joué à C5, est-ce que tu as réellement
réalise que tu perdais un pion.
cours de
cours Excuse
moi Non bien sûr Mais j'ai réalisé qu'à ce moment-là
les postes la position
devient assez technique simple et je
J'ai des contre-indications, mais je veux dire
Désolé, je veux dire, tu dis que c'est assez
Technique Mais moi, c'est possible que
Les noirs gagnent cette position. Non, et bien
c'est tu vois, c'est une question de sentiment
tu te connais bien, tu ne peux jamais pendant
Jeu d'échecs que vous ne pourrez jamais calculer
tout jusqu'à la fin mais ensuite toi
tu dois juste sentir où as-tu
suffisamment d'occasions défensives ou il a
suffisamment de ressources d'attaque pour gagner
donc tu devrais juste le sentir et je l'ai ressenti
ça devrait suffire pour faire un match nul
Bouge parce que si je ne joue pas à ce coup
Si je n'abandonne pas ça, quoi quoi
ce qui arrive, c'est que je fais 50 coups et ensuite
et puis si je le perds comme ça enfin
Il n'y a aucun moyen de défendre la position
plus encore
Euh donc
C5 UH Maintenant, eh bien, ma seule erreur était
que peut-être je passe trop de temps
calculer ces variations et je
j'ai commencé à entrer dans le temps vraiment sérieux
Problème alors il a joué la tour tak la tour C5
C'est normal donc la tour prend C5 Bishop prend
F6 donc c'est ça le point, n'est-ce pas, euh, toi
j'ai ça
à Oh désolé, il a ça ouais le point
est après la Reine Reine H6 Check Il a
Bishop G7 attaque à nouveau ma reine et
puis il prend la tour en C5 donc j'ai besoin
pour prendre Queen prend F6 D prend C5 ceci
Ouais, c'est la position. Eh bien, il est SP
En gros, mais UH, ma reine est très
bon sur F6 pour que je puisse obtenir des contre-parties
sa peau est beaucoup plus faible que la mienne et moi
J'ai aussi la ligne B, ce qui est très
important mais il a le Se ouais c'est
aussi un point assez important Yeah Point UM
mais maintenant, j'ai besoin de jouer car j'en ai besoin
organiser le contre-jeu Well Queen h8
Le contrôle était possible mais ensuite sa peau
se sent assez à l'aise sur H7, il y va
Reine E7 et k7 Si je joue Reine E5 pour
exemple je je je n'aimais pas la reine d5
centralisant ses pièces et puis je suis dedans
Un vrai problème mais je pense que j'ai réussi à le faire
trouver un très bon Move Kin H2
H Parce qu'alors je bouge mon R Le
le problème est que je ne peux pas jouer à R B6
immédiatement ici parce qu'il joue la tour
d1 Vérifiez et accouplez-moi sur H1 avec un
tour avec une dame à son choix donc je
besoin de jouer à ce déménagement prophylactique
En fait, je pense juste maintenant que tout ça
Jeux Tout ce jeu concernait
les prophylactiques que vous connaissez font les deux
Mouvements prophylactiques C'est un mouvement trèstique
maintenant je veux participer avec mon R to b i
je veux euh
contre-jeu et UH, ce n'est pas si facile pour
Lui pour l'empêcher en fait parce qu'il
doit améliorer la position de sa peau
Parce que pour le moment je ne le suis pas
menaçant de vérifier h8 mais un jour je
il le fera donc il devra jouer à un autre
Déplacement prophylactique Si vous avez trouvé s'il
j'ai trouvé la tour d5, alors vous pourriez vérifier h8
Ouais ouais alors déjà je
en fait, je pense juste
maintenant que peut-être, peut-être que je menace
tour d1 Ici tu sais O méchant ouais
Ouais, le fait est qu'After R prend
Dame check7 Reine prend A8 prenant le
Reine loin du tableau, donc euh, donc ça
est un autre Move King prophylactique j8
Juste pour éviter ce chèque et ensuite je suis
juste à temps Juste à temps pour organiser
contre-jeu en jouant la tour B6 Ici
attaquer en fait, mon idée est ma prochaine
bouge s'il joue un mouvement comme la tour c8
par exemple Eh bien, tout d'abord, je suis
menacer de prendre A6 aussi, ok
Voyons juste ça
cet autre
est après la tour c8 après la tour c8 pour
exemple I Je peux Jouer la tour prend E6 Ceci
est mon point de sacrifier la tour et
Après F prend C6 que prend G Il y a un
perpet che ne peut pas échapper au perpet
Vérifiez-le pour que
ça et aussi pas trop bon pour les noirs
Entrez avec sa tour Quelque part en d1 Ok
C'est l'une de nos grandes questions.
poules Après la tour d1 Ok menaçant I
je peux jouer à E4 ou F3, je ne sais pas ce que c'est
mieux Disons qu'E4, son problème est maintenant
que je menace la reine E5, je veux dire, je suis
entrer au rang E également, ok, donc
tout d'abord, Queen ne prend pas très
bien ouais à cause de la tour B Check et
tour h8 Fait du même genre
Je veux dire, le point est de savoir qui doit bouger
Parce que c'est absolument le
pareil et
et il ne peut pas, je veux dire, vraiment perdre le contrôle
de la course E parce que maintenant ma est reine5
suivi de la tour B, j'ai vraiment vraiment
Contre-jeu sérieux, je veux dire, il est peut-être là
Danger même si pourquoi tour encore
protégé sur un Si donc vous êtes définitivement
je pense que c'est la meilleure décision, ouais
définitivement ouais en fait, c'est le
seulement bouge presque, je peux voir que pendant
le jeu et maintenant maintenant j'ai fait un
erreur Maintenant, j'ai fait une erreur et j'ai été court
du Temps et dans mon calcul il me manque
quelque chose parce que bien sûr mon original
en fait, l'idée ici était de jouer à Queen C3
c'était mon intention initiale et ceci
C'était la bonne façon de jouer. Eh bien, juste
Un autre point est si je joue à Queen E5 maintenant
j'essaye d'attaquer le pion sur C5 alors
il a Queen d5 Move C'est très
important et je ne peux pas récupérer le pion
Parce qu'After Queen prend d5 E prend d5
il attaque sur E2, je n'ai pas le temps de choisir
ce pion A6 et après l'E3, il est juste
Dans Time to play rookie Six, protecteur
tout et il est là dans cette fin
Jeu I, j'ai quelques chances de faire un Dr
mais il s'est levé, je veux dire, c'est que ce n'était pas le mien
Plan mais la reine C3 la reine C3 était une bonne
Bougez et je pense que c'était presque le
Pour le tirage After Queen
C3 Parce que maintenant, il a besoin de se protéger
ça spwn comment comment le faire Eh bien, d'accord, laissez
moi TR tour C'est le coup principal et
puis la Reine C4 attaque Le pion sur
A6 donc c'est ouais et le point de mon
une erreur de calcul était aussi en fait, je pense
Je menace peut-être de reprendre l'E6
Le point que je veux dire, c'est que R C6 est dans le temps
pour tout protéger et il est debout mais moi
raté dans mon calcul, j'ai oublié
ce Move Queen pour l'avoir épinglé et UH
donc la tour C6 ne marche pas et puis
sinon je je crois que je prends simplement le
pa Tirage immédiat Dame d5 Je prends
sur A6 et dessinez-le simplement pour que ce soit
la façon de terminer ce jeu sans
Trop de soucis
mais bon, quand tu as joué à Queen F3, nous
J'ai pensé à un mouvement défensif brillant
Fantastique, la seule façon d'obtenir votre tour
prends un et bien, ce ne serait pas si mal
Déplacez-vous si ce n'est pas la reine C3, je veux dire si si je
je n'aurais pas la Reine C3. Peut-être que c'était ça
ce n'était pas une mauvaise décision
mais mais Après Queen F3 en fait Queen
prend F3 E prend F3 En fait je prends le
pion Retour en fait Il n'y a aucun moyen de
Empêche-moi de prendre le pion mais le
la tour n'est pas facile du tout pas facile du tout
Parce que je crois que G a gâché sa position
Ici, après la tour, la tour prend A6, euh, il est parti
C4 Et bien, il doit pousser sa tour SP D6
J'arrive juste à temps pour revenir avec mon
tour C3 tour
d1 et maintenant, en fait, sa décision était lui
J'ai pris une décision très étrange, je dirais
jouer la tour pour entrer dans ce domaine
car contre ce qui est bien, mon n'est pas ainsi
Simple mais c'est un match nul, je veux dire, nous deux
C'est un match nul en théorie, nous ne savons pas
Comment mais on sait que c'est nul Ok mais quoi
tu dis qu'il devrait déplacer son roi G7 I
était très inquiet de ce déménagement pendant
le jeu m'a beaucoup inquiété et son idée
est d'amener ses Kin au Centre à J4
Ok donc tu amènes ton roi ouais je
amène My King et il joue Kin F6 et
Disons Play Kin F1 Disons probablement
pas le meilleur Mo mais quand même K5
ou ouais, quelque chose comme ça et maintenant
Après K par exemple, il va
R.
et j'ai de sérieux problèmes ici, je veux dire
Je ne dis pas que je perds ici, mais c'est
Sérieusement, d'accord, donc le fait est que si vous
amène ton roi puis la tour prend et
soudainement ouais, mon roi est absent et si je
commence à protéger le pion puis il obtient
avec ses parents à D4, ce qui est très
Carré important Eh bien, je, je, je peux commencer
ce contre avec A4 je ne suis pas sûr que
Les noirs gagnent, je ne suis pas sûr. Peut-être que c'est le cas
a Peut-être que c'est nul Ouais tour A5
Ce n'est pas lui parce que
Une fois que tu sais s'il prend, ce n'est pas le cas
Simple mais voyez, je pense que si je commence
se sentir très mal à l'aise avec ouais
Eh bien, le fait est que disons qu'une fois qu'il
arrive ici, je peux le vérifier, ce n'est pas le cas
Simple Parce que s'il prend du A4, j'y vais
d s'il devient Kin, je peux jouer la tour B4 pour
exemple Ce n'est pas facile mais de
bien sûr très
Jeu dangereux F4 en fait après
F6 C'est
aussi F Eh bien, mon intention était de jouer à F4
Juste pour l'empêcher de venir ici mais
alors ce carré devient faible donc il peut
essayez Kin F5 Kin F3 et puis à un moment donné
Peut-être C2 tour C1 Check kin2 et ensuite il
peut venir à l'E4 par exemple si bien
Peut-être k d Peut-être que je le tiendrai avec K rook F3
K comme ça, il est peut-être temps de le retenir mais
Eh bien, vous voyez, dans un grave problème de temps
avec une telle pression, tu es au lit, je
c'est normal de s'inquiéter
ce que je veux dire, je ne suis pas sûr
C'était gagnant mais ça aurait pu être bien plus
des problèmes pour moi E5 un problème Il y a
c'est aussi possible Ouais, c'est ça EX
C'est la position Ouais, puis-je jouer, peut-être que je
il faut garder son
K un peu E peut-être
pas moyen de dis pas atast mais c'est
Pas vrai mais ça
était-ce sa chance, c'était sa
Chance mais il a joué assez vite la tour
Je ne sais pas pourquoi je ne sais pas pourquoi c'était
décision surprenante pour moi, tour et puis
Je joue la tour A1, la tour prend A2 et puis par
Force Nous arrivons à cette endame r prend3 r
prend F2
Vérifiez et je suis allé King G1 Kin H3 est également
possible mais c'est peut-être plus simple
parce qu'il ne peut pas vraiment utiliser
ce UH me coupe la main lors de la deuxième manche, je
je ne vois pas comment, ouais, je veux dire, c'est ça
mais c'est une grande décision K H3
Quoi et pourquoi avez-vous essentiellement préféré
ça, je veux dire, qu'est-ce que c'est exactement
tu dis que c'est faux avec le roi sur H3
Eh bien, le fait est qu'il commence
améliorer sa position et alors le seul
J'ai un plan, je dois jouer à G4 plus tard et
Après H G4, c'est très risqué pour moi de
prendre avec l'AP
[musique]
et
puis devient assez faible il met sa tour
sur H1 donc il ne devrait pas me permettre de jouer
H5 pour changer Un autre pa puis lentement
commence à venir avec un kein, tu le sais
Typique Typique Jouer F6 puis E5 My
je suis faible tu sais que je n'ai pas beaucoup aimé ça
beaucoup mais bon, je crois que c'est encore peut-être
un match nul avec une défense précise mais je veux
c'est ouais pas si simple R Quelque part
tour A2 Eh bien maintenant, le point de cette fin
Le jeu c'est que si mon père restait sur F2
alors c'est un tirage simple, il n'y a pas
En fait j'ai eu exactement le même End Game
Contre le même adversaire avec Quatre
PS contre trois quand où UH c'était
Las Palmas 96 dans le Tournoi de Las
Palmas l'a fait, Gary, joue-le sur UH Non, je
j'ai joué sur moi
C'était parce que j'étais debout. Eh bien, j'ai joué mais de
Bien sûr, je n'ai rien pu réaliser avec ça
un pa c'est Simple Drop Parce que myin c'est beaucoup
plus sûr ici ok mais aussi c'est très bien
je sais qu'une fois que tu as ce pion sur H4
bloquer le pion H alors voilà
Rien à faire, je veux dire vraiment le seul
De sérieuses chances de gagner sont quand le
le pion arrive ici et ouais, ça les crampe
pions corrects C'est correct et
Euh mais malheureusement mon pion est sur F3
et malheureusement les paes UH selon
aux échecs, R ne recule pas
je sais que je le ferais, je le ferais, si je le souhaite
jouer un 3 F2
Je le sais maintenant avec mes parents, tu sais
le premier rang, ce n'est pas si simple, c'est
Pas si facile de faire un tirage bien sur
c'est un match nul mais ce n'est pas si facile
Je sais qu'il l'a, il a des chances, et bien maintenant
Je ne me souviens pas exactement des Moves Next
Allons droit au but, ça n'a pas d'importance
pas parce que d'accord, mon plan est simple, je
je dois mettre My R sur les sept courses et
alors attends, attends qu'il aille bien
avant de faire quelque chose, donc il a aussi
pour jouer à E5, tout est très
normal, je pense que c'était ma position
était sur B7, c'était l'un des points critiques
positions, j'ai commencé à le vérifier pour qu'il
Je suis venu sur le tableau, ouais, et bien, c'était pour
jouer au Roi d5 C'était intéressant de jouer
Roi d5 mais j'ai vu que c'était nul par
Forcer je joue la tour F6 Roi D4 la tour prend
f73 donc il sacrifie Le pa mais il l'active
sa tarte mais il n'y a aucun moyen de la casser
à travers Parce que j'ai King G1 maintenant et
il ne peut pas vraiment prendre le relais en F3
Parce qu'une fois qu'il joue la tour F2, je toujours
avoir la tour 7 qui attaque son pa la tour 5
prend3 prend E5 Check avec match nul donc
c'était juste je devrais juste mentionner que c'est
pas très fort ouais c'est
pas l'homme pour terminer le match
alors il est allé en F5 et j'ai commencé à
Attaquez le R B7 F6
pour imprimer le et ici, je
j'ai fait une grave erreur, je dirais
une grave erreur. Eh bien, encore une fois, je
ça veut dire que j'étais un peu trop détends-toi déjà ici
J'étais un peu trop détendu parce que la tour G7
ce que j'ai joué c'était probablement mieux
Juste pour mettre la tour sur f7 Quelque part Juste pour
Arrêtez-le de ce plan en jouant à G55 fg5
Maintenant à cause du code PIN, alors il peut
revenir au je est le meilleur pour lui
tourner sur le Six R puis aller à l'intérieur
jouer à F5 ceci pour réaliser ce genre
de position puis essayez d'entrer avec A
K Eh bien, c'est un match nul de toute façon parce que je
J'ai commencé à donner des coups de pied au pa sur G6 mais j'ai vu
C'est la configuration la plus dangereuse qui
Pourquoi je voulais l'empêcher du tout, alors je
J'ai vu qu'après la tour G7 il ne peut rien faire
Le seul plan est de jouer au G5 mais
malheureusement pour moi, ce plan est tout à fait
Fort et Après G5 H G5
F comme tu te souviens de
sérieusement et euh je me rends compte que c'est très
Dangereux donc je veux dire en gros celui de Gary
Plan Voici pour jouer à G4 et créer un pa
Ouais ouais ouais c'est exactement le
Planifier et puis et il est important que
son skin est sur F5 donc une fois que je l'ai vérifié, il
Va à E4, c'est vrai. Ok, c'est un plan et
Eh bien, en fait, ce qui m'a manqué en jouant au tour
G7, je veux dire, c'est juste que je pensais que je le ferais
Commencez simplement à attaquer la tour H7 K G6
tour Se K F6 tour H7 Mais ian j'ai oublié
à propos de G4 Simplement qu'il ne le fait toujours pas
je dois protéger le pa, il peut jouer au G4
et je ne peux bien sûr pas prendre le H5
Parce que gf3 et deux pwns Pass je perds
donc de toute façon je dois prendre G4 et ensuite
Nous arrivons à cette position qui est moi
je pense que c'est un match nul, je pense que c'est un match nul
cette position Ok Parce que je veux dire dans le
la position exacte que vous aviez dans le jeu
C'était la tour G8 G4 qu'il ne pourrait jamais avoir
cette position dans un jeu Nous avions la tour
f8 Eh bien, le point maintenant que j'ai commencé
Pour calculer de nombreuses variations, ici, je
je ne voulais pas aller dans cette position, je, je
Je veux dire, je peux l'obtenir de toute façon, mais je ne l'ai pas fait
je veux accéder à ce type de poste
en plus, je crois que c'est un match nul, mais
avec une défense très très précise
Obtenons simplement la position exacte que nous avions
donc on l'a fait, je suis allé tour G8 tour G8 ouais il
Je suis devenu G4 ouais ouais j'ai commencé à le vérifier
tour f8 Vérifier
Euh, alors il est allé à E6 ou G6, tu te souviens
mélange un peu Ouais, il a joué, il
répété plusieurs fois alors il a joué
Ici
Ouais, vérifie, et bien, je pense que maintenant, en fait
mais mais à ce stade, je veux dire Gary F ouais
Ouais, Gary dit ça. Après ça
j'ai répété, je dois dire que c'était ce que j'avais
lui dit immédiatement après la fin de
Le jeu auquel vous devriez jouer Kin
F6
donne-le-lui après
Pourquoi je SP autant de timing Après G Parce que
J'étais inquiet
c'est seulement pour lui qu'il visait Win
Noir tu ne l'es pas
Parce que la défense très simple est mon idée
joue ici Eh bien, une des idées Juste
hbe prend je veux le baiser K s'en va vers
take3 le but est d'obtenir
Qu'est-ce que ça pourrait exprimer parce que mon
est beaucoup plus en sécurité ici une fois qu'il sort avec
R Je peux mettre mon entrée sur F3 et son H est aussi
beaucoup moins dangereux que le sur G4
Moi et un autre très important
la question est que dans ce genre de
position qu'il peut parfois sacrifier cela
et va dans ce qui est L pour moi, je
veux dire, c'est pour déménager, je peux démissionner et
Can Never Go Any End est un match nul et
Un autre point est que je peux toujours changer mon
je joue G4 avec des tours et puis je veux dire In
ce type de poste car je ne sais pas
Juste par exemple, ce genre de choses, je
jouer à G4 puis We Exchange et ensuite
L'endame avec E5 pa est un tirage simple
donc c'était UM, c'était assez bien
mais aussi je ne le fais pas je ne le fais pas
Je pense que c'est une victoire pour les Noirs, je ne le pense pas.
pense
donc je ne voyais pas de chemin, je veux dire, je veux dire, je
Est-ce que je n'ai pas eu assez de temps pour
analysez-le très précisément, ce que je vais faire
C'est après le match mais je ne le pense pas
Est
gagner Noir a de sérieuses chances Noir
je peux essayer mais je ne le suis pas, je n'en suis pas si sûr mais
si je me trompe, je le ferai, je te le dirai dans un
semaine où je me trompe mais ne t'inquiète pas ouais
donc mais After Kin F5 tour F Check je ne le fais pas
je sais ce que Gary a réellement manqué. Ici
Je ne sais pas parce que maintenant R Le point est
que peut-être qu'il voulait essayer f7 Peut-être que je
je ne sais pas et après la tour
G5 Maintenant, si gf3 et la tour prennent E5, c'est un
dessiner donc il doit jouer Kin F6 Mon Kin est
sur F Désolé, je dois jouer à Kin F6 et ensuite je
avoir F4 Peut-être que c'est le coup qu'il
Mademoiselle Parce que bien sûr, je veux dire les deux
les adversaires sont déjà fatigués et il est six heures
heures pour que vous puissiez même manquer ce genre de
Des mouvements simples, c'est très possible
Parfois UH et F4 e prend f g prend F4
et maintenant je veux dire normalement bien sûr Noir
devoir réussir devrait être la norme gagnante
mais le fait est qu'il n'y a aucun moyen de
défendre la norme sur H5 donc les Noirs doivent
jouez R H2 et la tour est très passive
sur H2 Roi G1 tour H3 Roi G2 et UH
Il n'y a tout simplement pas
je ne peux pas venir et la tour est très mauvaise
H3 et il n'y a aucun moyen d'améliorer
la position des noirs si les noirs essaient de rester
J'essaye aussi de rester tour H4 K G1 tour H3
K G Je reste juste avec moi Il n'y a pas
moyen de gagner cette position alors peut-être que ça
était
Ouais, je veux dire, il
semblait quand la triple répétition
est arrivé, il semblait presque
surpris C'était une curieuse fin à la
le jeu en fait, ouais, c'était ouais, c'était
Ok, comment ça va pour Time Eric
devrions-nous passer par un autre jeu ou faire
tu veux prendre un
Pause excellente devrions-nous 10 minutes 10
minute, pause, bonne et ensuite nous irons à
le prochain match ok 10 minutes de pause alors
nous passerons par le jeu UM 11 ouais merci
un
Parcelle
pas très intellectuel, j'en ai peur, mais
Quoi qu'il en soit, ici, nous y allons, alors maintenant nous sommes
je vais regarder le jeu UM
11 Où Gary Kasparov avait The White
pièces
et ok tu as changé ton ouverture vladimir
du mur de Berlin à l'archange
Pourquoi as-tu fait ça ? Eh bien, en gros, c'est
était
UH Juste j'ai changé One pire End Game en
Une autre fin de jeu pire, je veux dire en gros
c'est juste un genre de travail différent. Fin du jeu
mais non, je sentais que j'allais bien, je veux dire, je vais bien
J'étais prêt avant le match à défendre
un peu pire End Games et j'étais sûr
Je ne le perdrai pas et euh, je l'étais aussi
bien sûr, c'est très désagréable pour moi
Opp
et bien mais de
Bien sûr, parce que je joue à ce Berlin
Défense donc Berlin Défense en Première
Jeu donc c'est déjà un jeu numéro 11
il a donc eu beaucoup de temps pour se préparer
cette fin de jeu particulière et c'est pourquoi je
J'ai décidé de changer. Eh bien, c'est typique
pour Match Strategy Parce qu'alors il a
pour commencer à préparer une autre ouverture
Une autre fin à laquelle il s'agissait, c'est pour une
Je ne joue pas à lui, tu sais que c'est devenu clair
à lui seulement maintenant mais mais tu ne sais jamais que je
veux dire Parce que si ton adversaire joue
Une autre ouverture à laquelle vous devez vous préparer
c'est aussi mais pour moi c'était clair, je viens de
donne-lui du travail, je joue à ça, j'en suis sûr
Je vais bien le tenir, je veux dire, bonne chance
Je vais le tenir et ensuite il commence à travailler
sur la direction qui ne sera jamais
cela se reproduit alors donne-en juste un peu
travail supplémentaire pour votre adversaire. D'accord, je
je veux dire, tu as dit que ta stratégie était de
Exchange Queens UM que vous savez jouer
ces fins, je veux dire
quand tu as regardé les jeux de Gary
auparavant, je veux dire, as-tu ressenti un
dans une certaine mesure, c'était une faiblesse de sa part
pauvre en
fins Non pas du tout Eh bien, je ne le ferais pas
dire que ma stratégie était d'échanger
Queens, je veux dire, UH, ma stratégie n'était pas de
évitez d'échanger des reines, je veux dire s'il le fait
il m'aime, je veux dire, ça ne me dérange pas non plus
Echange mais j'ai compris que s'il
Je veux vraiment l'éviter, je peux le faire
Rien à ce sujet, je veux dire, je dois aussi
soyez prêt à jouer des positions pointues également dans
cette variante
était
assez
Pourquoi parce que c'était lui, je veux dire, ied
quelques ouvertures Où il peut CH et il était
Prendre cette capacité, c'est étrange
car je veux dire, penses-tu qu'il est certain
exent, il a perdu son sang-froid
Peut-être qu'il devrait faire mieux, mais c'était quand même le cas
assez étrange pour moi. Voyons E E5 Ouais
kn F3 kn6 Bishop B5 A6 Maintenant un peu
Changer ouais Bishop A4 kn
F6 B5 bish B bish C5 ce sont tous
Mouvements théoriques normaux mais c'est UM
devenir presque élevé
Coffre de haut niveau à la mode ce particulier
variation actuelle Dernières années
Eh bien, je dois dire que j'étais un peu inquiet à ce sujet
joue-le surtout contre G parce que je
savait qu'il préparait cette ligne
Très bien, je veux dire, en fait, nous étions
en regardant cette ligne Même ensemble dans
1995 Quand j'étais son deuxième pour le match
Contre un Nous analysons cette ligne ainsi et
Je savais qu'il faisait beaucoup de travail
après donc c'était un peu risqué
décision, je dois dire que c'était un peu risqué
alors il est allé A4, il a opté pour le Main
Ligne théorique Bishop B7 D3 Châteaux K
C3
B4 Non B4 est un coup théorique et je
est allé kn A5 B4 a été joué par un n'est-ce pas
Match en 95 ouais et j'y suis allé 5 je pense
il y a quelques années, cette mise en place
cette ligne était très populaire auprès de nombreux joueurs
j'ai essayé d'y jouer mais finalement
Final
décision était que les Blancs sont meilleurs en
cette ligne et puis certaines personnes se sont arrêtées
pour y jouer mais ce n'est pas si simple
K A5 UH alors comment ça se passe, ça prend presque B5
Forcer, je veux dire, ok, les blancs ont le choix
fait, les blancs peuvent jouer à Bishop A2 ici
Le chevalier prend C5 Ici, les Blancs ont un bon
Choix des Blancs mais mon adversaire a décidé de
optez pour le Main Line Knight B3 C prend
B3 a prend B5 la tour prend A8 Bishop prend
A8 Knight prend C5 El Force No et d5
Eh bien, le fait est que les Blancs sont clairement
Ici bien sûr mais contre compensation
Les noirs ont deux fous assez actifs
évêques et ok ce double pa je veux dire
ce B3 B2 P est assez faible donc ce I
je dirais que c'est seulement la moitié, la moitié, la moitié
avantage donc d5 Noir doit ouvrir le
Centre pour activer ses pièces son
évêques Ouais, je veux dire, c'est vraiment
La clé du poste n'est-elle pas parce que
tu as tes deux évêques dont tu as besoin
ces diagonales ouvertes donc d5 Juste en quelque sorte
explose
Cent donc par exemple si les Blancs essaient de
Prendre d5 kn prend d5 puis Mon Fou
commence à fonctionner très bien sur A8 et puis
Je pourrai à l'avenir organiser certaines attaques
du côté du roi pour que
Pourquoi Bishop G5 et en fait UM Gary ont
il a déjà eu ça avant, n'est-ce pas
Contre SH il avait ça, c'est précis
poste au conseil d'administration depuis quelques années
il y a prend E4 prend
UM mais j'ai le sentiment que là-dedans
poste de Chirov
joué correctement donc c'est votre nouveau
bouge disons ou est-ce que ça a été joué
avant Non, ça a été joué avant, je veux dire
Ce n'est pas entièrement nouveau, je veux dire ce mouvement
mais Bishop E7 était plus courant, je le ferais
dire mais ce mouvement presque par force
mène à ce UH Strange End Game D
prend E4 La reine prend d1 la tour prend d1
B4 Forcer maintenant si
S'en va puis je prends le père et une fois
Une fois que j'ai réussi, je n'ai aucun problème
alors croyez-moi, je l'ai beaucoup vérifié
soigneusement, il n'y a rien de mieux que
Bishop F6 B prend C3 Maintenant si G F6 kn D7 B
prend C3 B prend C3 C'est très très
important parce que
Si vous jouez à K D7 alors j'ai C2
Mouvement intermédiaire Regardons ça
Jetons un coup d'oeil à ça donc C2 attaque The
tour donc R doit se déplacer sur le côté et
Euh et maintenant je ne le fais pas
Rappelez-vous que je pense que ce n'était pas bon pour mais
je ne me souviens pas pourquoi nous prenons
le je pense que G prend F6 et le
Le fait est que si Knight prend f8 UH
Disons que le roi prend f8, la tour prend C2
Bishop D6 alors bien sûr je veux dire Black
a Bishop B6 Black a Aucun problème à
tout ça à cause de ce Pas faible, je pense que je
préfère plutôt la position des noirs à et
si je prends si je prends Bishop, alors si j'en ai un
Temp Play F3 est complètement gagnant mais
Le problème est qu'After R8 White est
incapable d'arrêter le pion sur C2 ouais, utilisation de
tour Parce que si la tour prend C2 alors la tour
d1 Mate et autrement Il n'y a aucun moyen de
Empêcher les Noirs de jouer la tour d1 Check
gagner pour que
Pourquoi, mais c'est simple, car ce n'est pas le cas
je m'attends à trop, alors je le prends en premier
G prend F6 kn
D7 Maintenant, euh, je ne peux pas jouer la tour d8
en gros, ce serait une bonne chose si My était
sur h8 par exemple Parce que kn prend C5
est impossible La tour est suspendue mais
puis kn prend F6 avec Check and Taking
La tour sur le 8 et le Fou sur Okay
Ouais, voyons juste ça K
F6 a découvert l'Attaque et maintenant R prend et
bien sûr, c'est gagnant pour les Blancs
Parce que The Bishop in the Corner est allumé
Okay, alors allons-y
retour UH pour que Pourquoi Bishop D6 Knight
prend f8 Le roi prend f8 Eh bien, les blancs doivent le faire
défendre le pion F3 Maintenant, à ce stade, je
veux dire, c'est fondamentalement la première fois
que l'un ou l'autre de vous avait vraiment fait une pause
réfléchi pendant un certain temps
et nous avons joué à What 21 Moves Here Yeah
C'est incroyable et il me semble m'en souvenir
Nous avons eu environ un quart d'heure de
Session, je veux dire, vous étiez juste
faire un blitz sur ces déménagements donc donc c'est
évidemment toute la préparation à la maison ouais
évidemment UM, je veux dire combien de temps
as-tu réellement passé du temps à analyser ça
très fin, cette fin précise, eh bien,
ce n'était pas seulement moi qui l'ai analysé aussi mon
L'équipe bien sûr ok et ton équipe ouais
Eh bien, peut-être qu'au total, je ne sais pas 30
heures Peut-être 30 heures de jeux d'entraînement ou
C'était juste une analyse. Non, Gary a joué.
Jeux d'entraînement comme il l'a dit, Gary joue
Ouais, car Gary a dit qu'il avait joué à un entraînement
Jouer avec cette position exacte, n'est-ce pas
Ouais ouais ouais Non, c'est juste, c'est juste, bien
Peut-être que je l'analyse moi-même pendant 10 heures
heures et puis j'ai j'ai compris
Des choses basiques et j'ai donné à l'autre
des gens à mon équipe juste pour terminer le
Principal, je veux terminer quelques variations
Juste pour que ce soit plus précis mais en
Choses de base que j'ai comprises Ok et bien je veux dire
Résumons simplement cette position UM I
ça veut dire que le jeu a commencé, ici ce jeu
J'ai commencé le Move 20. C'est assez calme
curieux donc c'est en fait plutôt un
inhabituel Type de fin, n'est-ce pas
Ouais parce que UM d'abord le matériel
Balance Ouais, la balance matière est
que les Noirs ont deux fous contre la tour
et deux Pas UH qui devraient normalement être
assez pour que les Noirs ne soient pas sérieux
problèmes Parce que deux évêques sont très
Fort surtout, c'est une sorte de semi-op
position Ce n'est pas très proche donc normalement
deux évêques, c'est une compensation suffisante pour
la tour et deux Pas mais là
Le noir est la structure B sur le K
Côté Disons si si je déplace mon pion en G6
si les Noirs avaient ce genre de
position, alors je veux dire, c'est juste un match nul
Il n'y a aucun moyen pour les Blancs de faire quoi que ce soit
mais avec un sur F6 j'ai une sérieuse faiblesse
Mon sur H7 en fait Mon Mon plan Ici l'un des
Mes plans sont d'essayer de
échanger une fois
ouais
quelque chose comme ça en H5 Disons M
Il n'y a aucun moyen de protéger le père. Okay, je
ça veut dire que c'est le point, n'est-ce pas
ce pa ne peut pas être protégé par un autre
papa et moi si ton roi vient
pour le défendre, j'ai des problèmes
ceci Parce que les Blancs ont potentiellement Deux
Deux contre un du côté de la reine et
parviendra potentiellement à créer un P
et j'ai besoin d'avoir mon roi près de ça
Pas pa pour le tenir mais ensuite je
j'ai un problème avec celui-ci jusqu'à présent
exemple si tu es roi, je ne sais pas comment
Nous, ouais, donc le plan blanc est ok, je ne le fais pas
Je sais que King vient ici quelque part et puis
Les Blancs commencent à pousser. Simplement Les Blancs commencent
pousser donc c'est le problème fondamental
ce pion faible auquel le roi est lié
défendre le pion faible et ensuite vous
Poussez vos pions du côté de la reine, ok
bien donc c'est définitivement noir qui doit le faire
quelque chose à ce sujet Eh bien, c'est en fait
C'est drôle qu'il n'y ait que
Un jeu dans cette fin de partie avant Oh It
a en fait été joué avant Ouais, le
même jeu et acte en fait, c'était un jeu
entre deux Grands Maîtres Sérieux I
je pense que Kuprik est vraiment contre Malanuk ouais
et UH, ce qui est drôle, c'est que blanc
j'ai réussi à perdre ce jeu, oh kupr était
Blanc Peut-être Ouais Okay C'est possible qu'il
Il y va, c'est un
joueur donc mais
UH donc H C'est le point de base, la clé du mouvement
du poste Maintenant Après H5
eh bien, c'est de mettre le sien sur H et après ça
Disons Bishop on5, je veux dire ce genre de
Set et After Bishop sur F4 Somewhere et
Alors que faire pour les Blancs avec ça ?
Pas si facile que King ne puisse pas aller au Centre
Parce que H2 pa est en panne, ok, allons-y
vois que nous y allons donc le K a
protège pa et si je joue à H
Ouais, si tu joues à H, tout le complexe de
Les carrés noirs sont faibles et maintenant il y en a
pas de problème pour moi de protéger ça, je peux
fais-le toujours en jouant à Bishop G3, mon pion
est très en sécurité ici et Black Again n'en a pas
problèmes et aussi la structure des pions
devient moins flexible du côté Kin
donc les Blancs ne peuvent pas vraiment organiser un Any Pass
et je n'ai pas besoin de mon roi, ici maintenant maintenant je
peut marcher avec même quelque part où être
Tu sais que je n'ai pas de FL protégé
Après H3 et je n'ai aucun problème
donc une fois, si je réussis ce genre de
Il y a très peu de choses que les Blancs peuvent faire
en fait, pour gagner la partie, les Blancs doivent
Arrêtez-le d'une manière ou d'une autre, alors pour ça
raison Dans cette position, Gary a joué
Point H4 Ouais bon bouge bien un autre
Un autre un autre
UH, l'idée pour arrêter ça était de jouer à G3
arrêter H4 aussi parce que maintenant H4 G prend
H4 et quelques problèmes avec ça mais
est la nuance F5 parce que maintenant le sur F3 est
suspendu et parce que pour moi aussi ouais
j'ai oublié de mentionner une chose que c'est
très très important que les Noirs changent
gérer F5 Break et changer ce SP
Parce qu'alors Bishop devient très actif
UH et aussi je veux dire, je me débarrasse de ça
Double P donc après G3 je suis juste à temps
C'est parti F5 Nous devrions le mentionner
Parce que j'aimerais jouer à E5 ceci
serait Gagner si pris
ck R prend A8
cependant, après E5, j'ai Bishop C5
Le chèque est
est très important Déplacer et jouer Suivant
k7 par exemple et puis je ne sais pas
que faire de ce F3 Il est faible et
Comment le roi Encore une fois, le roi ne peut pas
Vraiment, rapproche-toi parce qu'il le doit
je protège ça tout le temps, je veux dire
Cela peut facilement être pire très soudainement si
donc H ce H qui est définitivement le principal
Déplacez probablement le coup qui a été joué
Dans ce jeu d'entraînement de Kasparov I
ne le faites pas
savoir et
kin7 donc bien
fondamentalement, l'idée des noirs est de jouer à Let's
dit de conduire son évêque quelque part à D7
puis pour obtenir la pause F5
Eh bien ouais, un autre, un autre point est de
bien sûr, c'est très important que je ne puisse pas jouer
Bishop G3 attaque actuellement The pa on
H4 Il est impossible de le protéger mais le
le problème est à nouveau que la tour vérifie en prenant le
Bishop sur A8, c'est pourquoi je dois jouer
d'abord7 et maintenant si ce serait le noir
Bien sûr, les noirs joueraient Bishop G
Prendre le pion mais
UH, c'est Blanc qui doit bouger, donc roi
f2ed G Eh bien, maintenant, il faut obtenir ce F5
Pause immédiatement donc j'ai besoin d'abord de
activer mon évêque parce que ce n'est pas très
Fort avec cette structure
cet évêque donc je dois le mettre dans le
Un autre évêque diagonal plus actif
B7
UH et maintenant Eh bien, c'est le moment où je
Je suppose que oui, maintenant je pense que Gary a joué King
E3 est-ce exact, je ne suis pas lequel
Ouais exactement, c'est de cela que nous parlons
nous sommes sur le point d'aborder cela et nous venons
Nous le ferons UH Ne vous inquiétez pas, nous ne l'avons pas fait
je l'ai oublié Ray UM Maintenant, il jouait à C4
Ouais ouais et comme Ray Just l'a souligné
Je nous rappelle juste que Gary, en fait
a déclaré lors de la conférence de presse qui a suivi
que s'il jouait la tour A1, il disait que je gagnais
deux Temp sur le jeu et je gagne et
tu n'as pas vraiment défendu cette opinion
est-ce que tu es bien, tout d'abord, je dois mentionner
qu'il avait raison, la tour A1 est la
meilleur mouvement dans cette position C'est vrai
mais ce n'est de loin pas gagnant, je veux dire non
Les noirs ont une défense très sérieuse
ressources Ici et moi, je peux aussi changer un
un peu mon plan, je veux dire, je ne veux pas
pour entrer dans les détails sérieux parce que ceci
est une position d’importance théorique
alors peut-être que je joue à d'autres jeux avec
cette position donc je ne veux pas montrer
tout ce que je préparais After R mais
Quoi qu'il en soit, fais-moi confiance
Après avoir mis une certaine pression, Vladim, j'ai
j'ai appris à te faire confiance après ce match, ne le fais pas
je m'inquiète donc les Blancs ont une pression Après B C4
rook1 rook1 est plus précis C'est vrai
mais c'est très loin de gagner le
jeu très loin Si je veux dire, tu vois ça
poste Je connaissais ce poste Peut survenir
Si je pensais que White White était sérieux
des chances de gagner, je ne tenterais pas le coup, alors
C'est Soyons clairs sur ça
c'est toujours la préparation à la maison et nous y sommes
Quel mouvement faisons les choses correctement Mouvement 24
Préparation Still Home très intéressante
d'accord
donc C4 était
joué C'est un coup C4 très intéressant
très intéressant, je pense que c'est bien
Je n'y ai pas prêté trop attention
Bouge, je veux dire aussi, je le pense
a été analysé mais bon, un autre point est
qu'il est très difficile de se souvenir de tout
les variations que vous analysez, alors ok, juste moi
rappelez-vous que ce mouvement était possible mais
c'est tout ce dont je me souvenais tu sais
Eh bien, j'ai dû jouer à un jeu après C4
et ça fait beaucoup de
Sens C'est une sorte de semiting Move I
je le dirais, il faut maintenant que ce soit clair
Quels sont ses projets si j'essaie de déplacer un My
Bishop en ce moment Bishop c8 qui semble
être un geste judicieux en essayant d'obtenir F5
cette pause typique alors
dquare n'est pas sous
peut lancer la tour d5 pour que les blancs ne perdent pas leur température
lui-même jouant la tour 1, la tour A5 et obtient
Au cinquième rang immédiatement, donc c'est
pas très bien pour moi ok donc en gros
Ce pion est en difficulté, c'est H, et bien, je
Je peux toujours jouer à Bishop5 mais ensuite
pendant que la tour s'en va, puis G F4 pa
aura des ennuis pour
bien sûr, alors j'essaie d'aller à Push F, je veux dire
pour soutenir avec mon ce F5 mais ensuite tour
A1 est un alors R1 est un problème et il
ce serait bien mieux d'avoir ça
position Juste pour jouer C5 et mon Fou
sur Si mais après k6 Mon Fou ne peut pas
va vraiment à cette Diagonale C'est tout à fait
important et disons qu'après F5 E prend
F5 par exemple, ce n'est pas complètement forcé
mais par exemple prend disons la tour A5
Vérifiez le roi G6 UH
bien sûr j'arrive à jouer F5 Ma position
ce n'est pas trop mal mais le pa est toujours
faible sur H5 et mon Kin tu vois mon Kin est
Je veux dire, j'aimerais avoir mon parent
au Centre et C'est Ici par exemple
il peut me vérifier et je dois y aller même
H6 et ensuite il pourra revenir au Plan
d'UH poussant des pions du côté Dame donc
La position n'est pas simple ici, d'accord, alors
en gros, le roi est Just Way Out et
tu veux le garder au milieu
Ok donc ouais, de retour ici et C5 qui est
ce serait une bonne chose, je veux dire
normalement si je suis dans le temps parce que tu vois
ce pion de structure de pion sur C5 arrête deux
Pas C4 B3 mais ensuite j'ai commencé à avoir
quelques problèmes concrets Après la tour A1 et
mon évêque commence à être très vulnérable
Parce que disons Fou C6 tour A7
Vérifiez et UM assez ennuyeux parce que
Disons que je vais à Bishop D7 mais ensuite je peux
Ne jouez plus jamais à 5 et les Blancs ont alors
pl Même Parfois Eh bien tout d'abord le
normal c'est de jouer G3 F4 Peut-être F5 Même
Plus tard, je veux dire Ici, Black ne peut pas vraiment
Déplacer, la seule chose que les Noirs peuvent faire est
attendre Il n'y a aucun moyen et je ne peux pas jouer
C5 plus F5 je veux dire et après je peux seulement
attends et les blancs ont par exemple ça
Plan simple mettant pa sur F5 Limite Le
Évêque Maintenant, vous voyez, l'évêque a beaucoup
Quantité limitée de pressions, puis laissez
Rester
Sur Yeah Kin F3 G4 créant The Pas pa
et puis le pion H devient vraiment vraiment
Dangereux, ouais, tout d'un coup, avec huit mouvements
d'affilée pour Wi-Fi, ça a l'air plutôt
Dangereux et UH, alors pourquoi, pourquoi je
je pense que je passe environ 50 minutes ici
je pense ouais à mon avenir et je te connais
Nous manquons de choses à
dis-le, c'est pour ça que c'est la seule manière
jouer, c'est jouer à Bishop
E5 iiz C'est la seule façon de jouer
tour d'arrêt
A1 et maintenant mon idée est de jouer à C5 et moi
Ne laissez pas sa tour monter aussi. Une fois qu'il
Vient au Cinquième R. Je l'empêche de
attaquer le pa sur H5 donc ce coup est
très sensé UH mais UH Eh bien, il y est allé
tour D2, ce qui était un coup un peu surprenant
pour moi je dois dire que c'est très
principal Après Bishop5 très principal
Move était de jouer B4 bien sûr pour commencer
en poussant, puis je commence, je veux dire
attaquant ce Bishop C3 en jouant pour
exemple Ceci est une variation possible
attaquer ça Après B5, j'obtiens enfin
un blocus Bishop devant Bishop C5
alors un autre évêque peut venir à E6, je peux
je ressens une sorte de pression sur eux
Pas Parce que Maintenant avec My Bishop sur C5 pour
exemple Disons ce genre de configuration Si
Je gère alors c'est très difficile de
Créer un pion Pass et toujours le pion
Le pion C4 sera faible. D'accord, mais je suppose que c'est le cas.
en attendant j'amène My King en D3
Quand j'essaie de rompre
d'un
des moments où tu tiens bien, je veux dire après
bon nombre d'heures à analyser cela
position, je me rends compte que les noirs sont défensifs
les ressources sont très élevées, je veux dire, ce n'est pas le cas
à propos de Ce n'est pas vraiment concret
variations C'est une question de général
Sentir que le blanc est meilleur
maisli C'est un peu trop lent, je veux dire
je dirais que c'est un peu trop lent parce que
il veut le même genre de plan mais maintenant
Je suis juste déjà dans le temps
à UH pour créer la configuration que je souhaite
Alors qu'est-ce que c'était C5 je pense que je
est devenu la tour A2 UH et UH je pense que j'ai joué
Bishop C8 n'est-il pas meilleur
Vérifiez la tour UH
D C4 B B5 tour D2 b c i bish
C n'a pas d'importance R2
Tour C5
D Ouais parce que le problème de C5 c'est la tour
A2 Quoi qu'il en soit, et puis donc premier évêque maintenant
si la tour A2 est maintenant prête, alors je peux peut-être même
Jouez à F5 ou mettez My Bishop sur E6, je suis dedans
Le temps est très important et après la tour5
Eh bien, c'est en fait comme ça que ça se passe
dans le jeu, c'est différent, donc n'importe lequel
tour d5 Fou E6 tour A5 donc blanc
a finalement réussi à mettre sa tour sur le
Cinquième R et maintenant il est prêt à démarrer G3
F4 Play mais les noirs sont là juste à temps
Après C5, vous voyez la grande différence
ce Fou en D7 et tour
A7, ce code PIN est très désagréable pour moi
je ne peux pas vraiment faire grand chose, je ne peux pas jouer à F5
mais un évêque sur6 maintenant s'il commence
je me vérifie, je peux, je peux déjà y aller avec
Ici
F Ceci
est une fois
je dois déjà être égal et bien sûr
la tour prend papa, c'est impossible ouais la tour
prend5 bish Check Ouais donc je pense
i3 Fou D4
Vérifiez D3 et maintenant Eh bien
maintenant des variations très importantes, je veux dire maintenant
Le tout premier jeu commence parce qu'une fois
J'ai réussi, je suis passé à F5 Une fois que j'ai réussi à F5
Les blancs doivent jouer sinon il n'y aura pas
avantage du tout donc maintenant c'est ça devient
assez Force
B4 F prend
C4 bien sûr, en gros, j'aimerais
changer autant de Pas que
possible mais UH K prends C4 Bishop F2 mais
bien sûr, c'est très mauvais pour moi
Échangez-les parce qu'alors deux passes
lui donc évêque F2 Comment c'était B tak C5 I
je pense que Bishop prend
H4
C Et bien maintenant, ce Double n'est pas le cas
Dangereux je veux dire C6 ce H était très
Dangereux
parce que je pourrais dire si ça prend
sur H SO C'est, je veux dire, je ne devais pas le faire
inquiet à propos de ces deux, il en a deux
P Parce que c'était clair, je vais prendre
c'est les deux Tu es GL Débarrassez-vous de
que H parce que parfois peut
Créer pour que C6 Roi D6 la tour prenne H5 donc à
le moment Maintenant, les Blancs sont à égalité avec Trois PS Up
Je veux dire que les Blancs ont déjà frappé Three PS
pour deux évêques mais la position devient
Ouvrez ces Pas ne sont pas si forts en fait
Ils sont faibles et le voici
C'est dans le temps de dessiner ici bish
F2 et
G4 UH Et bien, il n'y avait aucun moyen de se protéger
ce SP déjà K prend la tour C6
H2 Eh bien, le seul Eh bien, en fait, j'étais
Je me souviens juste d'avoir essayé de calculer ça
genre de variations tour H par exemple
C6 de F
c'était une chance de jouer
pour une victoire mais alors je crois que Bishop3 si
si je ne me trompe pas, cette décision était bonne
assez et prend ensuite par exemple
Kin F5 King d5 Eh bien, j'ai le temps de le faire
faire un tirage au sort ok c'est juste c'est juste un
Question de calcul, ouais, c'est juste une question
de calcul donc tour H2 Eh bien ce n'est pas le cas
intéressant Bishop C5 I R C2 je suis allé F6
Eh bien, c'est clair que
Les blancs ne peuvent pas vraiment gagner car s'il
Veut pousser un des siens, il peut créer
Disons deux mais une fois qu'il commence à pousser
il doit abandonner l'un des siens, un autre
Une fois et puis, pour moi, cela suffira
Une telle position Juste pour abandonner l'un des
évêques pour ce SP et puis c'est atique
dra Ouais, faisons juste en sorte que ce soit clair, c'est
un match nul C'est en fait ce qui s'est passé
enfin
Okay, voyons juste la finale.
Se déplace très vite donc après F6 je pense
il a joué la tour H2, n'est-ce pas UH ouais je
je pense ouais tour H2 I
réfléchis et puis je pense que c'était R H6 Eh bien
Encore une fois, je veux dire que les Blancs veulent en créer deux.
Passer des pions mais je veux dire ce genre de
position serait un peu dangereuse pour
Noir s'il a réussi à prendre cette ponte
en toute sécurité mais bien sûr, il n'est pas à temps
pour ça, comment c'était Bishop d5 Check Yeah
bish d5 Vérifiez King F5 et ensuite je pense
tu as pris ici ouais Bishop prend F3 et
G5 G5 Dernière fente désespérée des Blancs
mais ça ne va vraiment nulle part King d5
et maintenant, en fait, nous sommes un excellent RW
Parce que disons s'il passe bien au G6 ou
gf6 alors mon évêque contrôle toujours f8
Carré, je peux toujours abandonner mon évêque
et après le G6 ça pourrait être dangereux
Parce que ce n'est pas si facile à contrôler
ces carrés mais je suis dans Time for Bishop
si pour Chèque et À Prendre sur G6 et
enfin, pour abandonner mon évêque, King prend
F6 Bishop prend la tour G6 G6 et
Euh tirage théorique excellent ok très
très intéressant
D'accord, je pense que nous allons prendre un court
Pause De temps en temps et plus tard Vladimir
je vais passer par certains de ses
premiers matchs de son début de carrière
de ses ses meilleurs jeux ok on se verra
dans environ 15 minutes, ok, très bien, à bientôt
alors merci
toi
avant avant Nous entrons dans le réel
jeux UH, je devrais mentionner que nous ne le sommes pas
je vais faire beaucoup d'analyses sur
ces Jeux, nous allons vraiment les faire
Je te les montrerai pour t'en montrer
des moments UH les plus excitants du
carrière mais si vous êtes intéressé par le
analyse approfondie des jeux dont il s'agit
disponible le livre de Vladimir dans ma vie
Jeux disponibles partout où se trouvent les bons livres
Vendu et en cela Il a littéralement
des centaines de ses Jeux avec des commentaires et
beaucoup d'informations sur sa biographie
Contexte et résultats afin que nous ne soyons pas
je vais dupliquer tout ça, me voici
je vais poser quelques questions, juste euh
nous n'allons pas passer trop de temps
parler de ce que c'était quand
Vladimir était un petit garçon parce que
en le regardant, c'est difficile de le croire
J'ai toujours été un petit garçon, alors à la place, UM
Demandons simplement à quelques-uns des
les traditionnels UM ce qui t'a attiré
aux échecs Quand as-tu commencé à jouer
aux échecs Eh bien, je pense que j'ai commencé à jouer
échecs Quand j'avais cinq ans, mon père m'a dit comment
le faire et je ne sais pas exactement ce que je
Je veux dire, quelle était l'attraction des échecs ?
J'ai tout simplement beaucoup aimé. Je ne sais pas
pour quelle raison et depuis que j'ai cinq ans ou
À six ans, j'ai commencé à travailler dessus
très, je veux dire, très dur, c'est tout simplement ça
C'était un plaisir pour moi de travailler aux échecs.
je ne sais pas pourquoi ce n'est pas très typique pour
pour un enfant, je veux dire les enfants normalement
aime généralement jouer au football ou
quelque chose
Sinon, mais pour moi, j'ai simplement beaucoup apprécié
beaucoup et où avez-vous obtenu votre premier
enseignement formel des échecs
École UH Eh bien, dans ma ville natale, j'étais
né en toaps qui est sur la scène de
En Russie, dans ma ville natale, il y avait un
petite école d'échecs très peu pour
sept huit UH Boys et j'y suis allé, je
je pense que j'étais
Six ans et très jeune à sauter
Un peu en avance tu avais l'unique
hor en 1992 d'avoir été invité à Votre
l'équipe olympique d'échecs du pays quel âge
Étiez-vous alors et comment avez-vous réussi à
rejoindre l'équipe Eh bien, je n'avais que 16 ans et
en fait, je n'en avais pas
Titre international jusqu'à présent, j'étais juste un
Nourrir le maître parce que j'ai gagné en 91
a remporté le Championnat du monde junior et
Feed Master mais ma note était assez élevée
déjà
Mais je n'en avais pas autant
Tous les autres MERS de l'équipe mais c'était
en fait
mononent gpar
qui a participé à une sorte de réunion de
La fédération russe des échecs va m'y emmener
cette équipe parce qu'il a probablement ressenti cela
J'ai un potentiel pour devenir très fort
Joueur et désolé, il voulait
à Just I Was aussi un de son école donc il
Je voulais que je joue là-bas et
finalement il a réussi il a réussi et moi
a montré un très bon résultat tout d'abord
Nous avons gagné les Jeux olympiques de Russie et moi aussi
Moi-même Montrer Le très bon Personnel
résultat
là, UM, c'était ton premier majeur depuis longtemps
voyage à l'étranger Hors du pays euh pas
vraiment le premier parce que j'ai joué
de nombreux championnats du monde juniors je pense
au Brésil en
Argentine C'est assez loin de Mos
mais c'était la première fois que tu avais le
Chance de rencontrer tous les joueurs du CH que vous
je les avais seulement lu et étudié
jeux et tous les meilleurs joueurs du
monde Qui participaient Ouais, c'est
C'est vrai que c'était très intéressant pour
moi parce que ça t'effrayait un peu
je sais jouer contre eux mais c'était
très intéressant et j'ai réalisé que je
je peux le faire, je peux rivaliser avec eux pendant
cet événement dont tu te souviens, qui tu es le plus
nerveux à l'idée de jouer aux Olympiades, UH
Je pense que oui parce qu'il a un gros
nom en fait et mais j'ai réussi à battre
lui avec Black Quoi qu'il en soit, c'était un
Jeu plus long donc nous n'allons pas prendre un
Regardez ça maintenant, à la place, nous sommes
je vais regarder ton match contre
Lupuan de Debren et UM c'était un
jeu dans une Défense qui est apparue dans ce
Match également The Grunfell Defense and So
jetons un coup d'oeil à cela maintenant
Jeu donc ok c'est UH D4 kn F6 C4 G6
Le chevalier C3 d5 C prend d5 Le chevalier prend
d5 E4 prend prend Fou G7 Fou B5
Vérifiez C'est l'une des possibilités
Systems Again La défense gref que j'aime bien
Le système était très présent en 1992 et je
j'y ai joué assez souvent
Le temps en fait, c'était un peu étrange
Choix de
myonent est un joueur classique très connu
et il aime jouer avec d'autres
ouvertures classiques plus classiques
normalement, donc définitivement il l'était
préparé pour cette ligne que Bishop E2 C5
Chevalier F3 cd4 cd4 Reine A5 Vérifiez bien
Tout cela est un jeu de terrain typique, je veux dire
Rien de vraiment félicitable pour Bishop D2 Queen
Châteaux A4
Castles Queen prend A4 Bishop prend F4
donc donc même maintenant tu aimes les jeux
Sans le
Reines
Eh bien, le fait est que juste deux tours
avant ce jeu, j'avais le précis
position J'avais cette position dans le jeu
Contre les mamies hongroises Gros Petter
et UH, j'ai fait une précision, voici la tour
fc1 puis La position est devenue égale
et très vite nous avons convenu de dessiner mais je
préparé un peu bien sûr pour ça
jeu et je pense que le coup que j'ai fait est la tour B1
est beaucoup plus fort en attaquant Le pa sur B7
immédiatement
Eh bien, ce n'est pas très bon pour Black de
jouer B6 Parce que normalement les Noirs veulent
obtenir ce genre de configuration E6 Bishop C6
attaquer le pion sur 4 puis Bishop
reste avant tout, il reste lui-même. Eh bien
sur C6 et aussi il protège pa sur B7 et
puis Knight commence à sortir de B8 et
C'est exactement ce que mon précédent
l'adversaire a finalement réussi à le faire et le
position Était égale Ici Le Point de
ce coup est que si Noir essaie de faire
les mêmes bish C6 et d5 sont possibles et
n'a pas de temps pour E6 et B6 n'est pas très
chanceux parce qu'alors tout le complexe
de carrés blancs devient faible et alors
Les blancs obtiennent un sérieux avantage à la fin
C'est pour ça qu'il est parti
E6 UH, j'essaie définitivement de devenir Bishop C6
Ensuite, et bien sûr, la tour prend B7
est le mouvement le plus critique ici, mais le
Le fait est que, bien sûr, l'idée des noirs est
pour récupérer le pion, retour en jouant à Bishop C6
tour C7 C'est bien sur C'est bien mieux
pour que les Blancs gardent la tour au rang S
Où c'est très actif et Bishop prend
E4 maintenant
UM En fait, je veux dire, la structure des pions est
Bon pour le noir et le noir prend le contrôle
en fait, tous les deux évêques sont actifs et
Une fois que les Noirs parviennent à jouer kn C6 pour obtenir
ses morceaux loin, je veux dire de ce B
carrés
alors UH, définitivement, Black sera
bien, donc les blancs doivent se dépêcher ici, pourquoi
je sais
G5 attaquant The Bishop sur E4 Bishop
d5 Fou
B4 Un autre
Move Black n'a toujours pas de temps pour Knight
C6 donc les Noirs doivent éloigner leur tour donc
la tour d8 la tour E8 était pire parce qu'alors
Après Fou B5 tour d8 C'est seulement
Square disponible pour les R et
Bish, la tour n'a plus de cases et
Les blancs gagnent donc cette tour
d8 et maintenant Bishop B5 c'est très
important
à Ce n'était pas si simple si je prenais le
pion sur f7 Après prend f7 par exemple
la tour D7 est possible en attaquant le kn sur
f7 et après la tour prend7 prend7 finalement
Pièces noires Homme à obtenir
et j'ai besoin de mon G par exemple et
prend son dos, prend D et probablement
la fin est
égal pour que pourquoi je n'ai pas besoin de me dépêcher
Prendre ce pa sur f7, c'est bien plus
important de limiter cela
bon sang, pourquoi bische
B5 contrôlant ce D7 C6 squ
et toujours en gardant le noir inachevé A6
Évêque
A4
Eh bien, les Noirs ne peuvent pas faire grand-chose, car à quoi
je veux prendre le pa sur f7 alors le
la position des noirs sera détruite et
A5 semble être seulement Move UH parce que maintenant
Les noirs obtiennent ce carré A6 pour leur chevalier
donc A5 attaquant The Bishop Bishop
E7 et Chevalier
A6 UH Eh bien, il n'y avait pas d'autre moyen de
jouer mais ici bish prend maintenant c'est
déjà
res8R
A7 Attaquant à nouveau The K donc tout ça
le jeu concerne One Temp, en fait Black Is
il manque toujours celui-là Temp à à
développer ses pièces et être ok donc
tour A7 Fou
C4 défendant The K sur A6 et At The Same
Temps d'attaque La tour allumée
La F1 prend
Maintenant, Bish prend D s'il essaie de
R alors la tour C1 est possible et disons
la tour prend f7 la tour prend f7 K prend f7
la tour prend C4 et les Blancs sont Simplement facilement
gagnant
c'est pourquoi Bishop prend
D4 attaque La tour Sur S mais ensuite
Simply Knight prend d8 Bishop prend A7
tour C1 et enfin Après tout, je veux dire tout
ces complications, bien sûr, nous avons dû
calculer De nombreuses variations sur la façon dont je
je veux dire, je le montre très brièvement
bien sûr, il y avait beaucoup de lignes différentes
UH et enfin enfin White est Exchange
et a une position techniquement gagnante
et UH aussi en fait je me souviens que mon
l'adversaire était déjà en Serious Time
Des problèmes et j'étais beaucoup plus jeune que et
ma tête était très propre et je me souviens que je
je passe seulement 25 minutes pour ce jeu.
ai-je pu calculer les variations
très très rapide pas comme maintenant j'en ai besoin de 40
Minutes pour calculer chaque ligne
à l'âge de 25 ans
Ouais, donc la tour C1 Bishop prend A2 et maintenant
tour
c8 Ouais Désolé tour c8 et en fait Le
Le problème des noirs c'est qu'il perd aussi un
Ici kn Veut aller en C6 avecck et
puis prenez l'évêque sur l'A7 de cette façon
il éloigne son Fou Bishop B6 et
maintenant kn B7 Vérifiez et ici en fait mon
adversaire avec son drapeau sur le point de tomber
résigné car après le roi G7 tour C6
UH White prend un autre morceau
donc, c'est
ça va, ok, donc c'était l'un de tes premiers
des succès notables dans
1992 et UH Après ça, tu as enfin le
Le monde a finalement découvert qu'il y avait un
Joueur nommé vad Qui pourrait jouer au jeu
et tu dois faire en sorte que ta dette soit en ligne
Et évidemment tu as été un habitué
visiteur Depuis, pouvez-vous nous dire
quelque chose sur l'expérience Linaris
Pourquoi ce tournoi est-il différent de
Tous les autres tournois bien chez les gens
parce que UH Linaris est un peu comme ça
comme Wimbledon dans le tennis et bien toi
je sais ce que c'est
en fait et c'est pourquoi toujours dans
linéaire
c'était toujours le meilleur tournoi de l'année
Toujours avec tous les meilleurs joueurs
y compris parp et ça devenait
De plus en plus fort chaque année et
C'est pourquoi, bien sûr, ça joue en premier
temps dans
Linar était très important pour moi. Comment
Qu'est-ce que je montre ? Qu'est-ce que je veux jouer ?
par exemple, ce fut un gros échec pour certains
les gens par exemple demandent qui puis plus tard
est devenu un Joueur très CH et Qui a joué
Match contre kpov UH pour le monde
Championnat mais son premier Linaris était un
c'était un gros désastre, je pense qu'il en a perdu 10
Jeux sur 13 dans ses premiers linaires donc
mais en plus il était déjà un sérieux
grand-mère Grand-mère très connue mais
il
il ne pouvait pas garder ses nerfs au frais et
puis il a commencé à perdre parce que
les adversaires sont très sérieux et vous savez
dans de tels tournois Une fois que vous commencez à
Perdre Tout le monde veut te battre
savoir devenir
Tout le monde vient à un jeu pour dire : Eh bien
allez, je dois jouer à Kasparov demain
et puis Après-demain kpov et
mais mais aujourd'hui, j'ai besoin d'en acheter
Points Aujourd'hui, vous connaissez ce genre de
Les choses et c'est pourquoi c'était très
important de s'y tenir et de montrer
résultat raisonnable et j'ai réussi
terminé sur Plus deux UH pariant ianuk Who
c'était bien, je veux dire, à ce moment-là
vraiment je veux dire vraiment génial et et je
manager Pour battre et quelques meilleurs joueursk I
J'ai perdu quelques matchs mais en général
c'était une très bonne performance et je pense
J'ai partagé quatre cinquièmes places sur 14
joueurs 14 meilleurs joueurs du monde donc
Je pense que les gens d'After The Tournament
j'ai commencé à me prendre au sérieux quand tu
J'ai participé à ce tournoi, c'était le tien
je crains que ce soit votre vrai test
que tu devais prouver que tu appartenais
avec les grands garçons Eh bien, peut-être que maintenant je
ça veut dire que si ça arrivait maintenant, ce serait
mais il est temps que tu saches quand tu n'as que 17 ans
tu ne penses pas à ces choses-là
Vas-y et joue, je veux dire, c'était juste
Tout simplement très intéressant pour moi, je veux dire
rencontrer Kasparov la première fois que je jouais
Kasparov était là et c'était ma première fois
J'ai joué Anatoli Karpov là-bas, je veux dire
la carte n'est pas dans la carte SIM, vous le savez
ça pourrait normalement arriver mais sur le tableau
et j'ai réussi à dessiner avec les deux
et en fait avec pov je gagnais mais
il a réussi à se défendre et c'était simplement
très très excitant mais je ne l'ai pas vraiment fait
pense
à propos de l'échec tu sais que je m'en fichais donc
je veux dire, quand tu as 17 ans, tu ne le fais pas
tu ne te soucies pas du tout de rien, toi aussi
intrépide quand tu as affronté Gary pour le
première fois et a-t-il appliqué son Full
techniques d'intimidation et vous regarder
Vers le bas et se concentrer dur à
Et bien, le jeu n'a pas duré
pendant trop longtemps en fait c'était c'était un
une position assez pointue mais alors nous nous
j'ai dû faire trois répétitions
Parce que sinon chacun des joueurs
ça deviendrait, je veux dire, ça deviendrait pire
Simplement, nous devions le faire, je veux dire, c'était
d'humeur combative mais nous avons dû faire un
dessiner mais c'était très intéressant c'était
Quoi qu'il en soit, je veux dire, c'était quelque chose de spécial, je
veux dire, c'est d'abord que je me souviens que je vais
Je me souviens de toute ma vie. C'est ainsi que c'était
votre premier super tournoi mais ensuite vous
j'ai fait autre chose euh peu de temps là-bas
Ce qui n'est pas quelque chose que beaucoup de jeunes
les joueurs le font vraiment même si vous devez le faire
fais-le pour jouer pour le championnat du monde
C'est-à-dire jouer des matchs et c'était très
intéressant que tu aies joué des matchs avec
deux personnes qui allaient devenir très
je te connais Miguel Ieskus et
Joël Latier et Joël est là s'il le peut
Venez et maintenant en tant que second de M.
Kramnick a un coup de main pour Joel
La Juste quelques questions
Vous êtes vous-même un joueur de haut niveau et
Comment se fait-il que vous deveniez assistant
pour préparer Vladimir et Quel était le tien
en pensant Eh bien, en fait, j'ai très suivi
de près Ce qui s'est passé en 95 entre UH
tu connais le prof UH C et Anand et là
il y avait un grand gars en arrière-plan qui
j'apprenais beaucoup UH et je pensais
Eh bien, c'est une chance que vous ne devriez pas laisser
Passe et bien sûr quand il m'a invité à
une seconde, j'ai sauté sur l'occasion
et avez-vous beaucoup appris pendant cela
Correspond Oui, énormément en fait, je pense
J'ai appris plus au cours de ces six mois
que UH que disons dans les trois derniers
années ou quelque chose comme ça euh, l'intensité de
le travail a été très génial, je veux dire
Nous avons travaillé très dur et UH
bien sûr, ce n'est jamais facile quand on a
Tu as des ambitions toi-même, tu sais UH UH
Donnez-lui tout votre temps et votre énergie
pour travailler pour quelqu'un d'autre mais euh et bien
Vladimir est un très bon ami de
Le mien depuis de nombreuses années et UH je dois
dis aussi admirer ses euh ses échecs
comprendre, je pense que c'est assez unique
et UH, je pense qu'il l'a prouvé dans ce cas
Match C'est en fait le meilleur jeu d'échecs
Joueur mondial en ce moment et UM
Eh bien, ok, pardonne mon humeur lyrique aujourd'hui
mais parfois j'ai l'impression que Kaisa tu sais
la déesse des échecs parle à travers
ce jeune homme quand il te montre
connais certaines de ses idées et je pense
Les spectateurs l'ont entrevu
Aujourd'hui et UH, crois-moi, il nous a montré
des choses incroyables pendant ce match
et ma dernière question est UM, est-ce que tu
s'attendre à participer au
qualification pour défier Vladimir pour
son titre dès que tu peux
Nous avions un petit plan secret maintenant que je
peut divulguer UH donc Vladimir était à battre
Gary et moi sommes allés à Win New Delhi et ensuite
Nous avons un match amical pour nous réunir
Tout le monde va bien, merci beaucoup
grand-mères
battre
UM Passons maintenant à UH et à We as We Head
en 1994 UM Maintenant tu es à cette période
Tu joues aux échecs très sérieusement
Vous travaillez très sérieusement, n'est-ce pas
quoi que ce soit pour se détendre pendant cette période ou
est-ce que tu étudiais les échecs tout le temps
Bien sûr, pas tout le temps, mais
UH Non, j'étais juste un garçon normal, je veux dire, 18 ans
19 années
La vieille vie semble être excellente
tout est très intéressant
intéressant ok ok tu en as
des entreprises, des amis, je veux dire, peut-être
Parfois je n'étais pas assez sérieux
peut-être que ça m'a affecté parce que je je
je pense que j'ai plutôt bien joué en 94
J'étais, je pense, le numéro quatre mondial
déjà quand j'avais 18 ans et mais euh j'étais
pas assez sérieux probablement pour y parvenir
quelques grands objectifs donc je jouais quelques
jouer bien, très stable, gagner de
De temps en temps, mais peut-être que cela ne fonctionne pas
aussi dur que tu devrais travailler
pour devenir quelque chose de spécial et toi
tu as déjà mentionné G Kamski, il ne l'a pas fait
a fait de bons débuts à Lenaris mais il l'a fait
viens jouer contre toi et UH, comment s'est passé
ça va ouais pas très bien ouais pas trop
bien bien
UH tu sais que beaucoup de choses sont quelque chose
Spécial Beaucoup est toujours quelque chose de spécial
donc
normalement c'est très difficile à casser
cette sorte
ou bien, parfois, il arrive quelque chose
Ça va mal depuis le début du
Correspond d'une manière ou d'une autre à ce que tu n'as pas l'impression d'être
dans un bon M pour jouer certains que vous ressentez
pas de chance, quelque chose ne va pas et
alors c'est très difficile de le casser toi
il faut avoir un esprit vraiment très fort
caractère très Fortes motivations à
Casse-le et avec Gataksk c'était à moi
Première grande expérience comme celle-ci et première
la fois où je suis venu au match, j'étais un
préféré UH dans un public, j'étais, j'en avais plus
les succès, je veux dire, UH, ma note était plus élevée
et en fait tout le monde s'attendait à ce que je le fasse
Gagner
UH mais peut-être que je ne me suis pas aussi bien préparé
je pouvais et puis je suis arrivé à un jeu et
alors quelque chose ne va pas, tu sais et moi
je ne pouvais pas, je ne pouvais pas le briser, je ne pouvais pas
Casse-le et finalement j'ai perdu ce match
c'était un match de candidature pour le monde
Quart de championnat et UH Eh bien, je
j'ai dû partir, je veux dire, en pensant
à propos
Championnat du monde pendant un moment, je le pense
c'était mais UH c'était très important
leçon je dirais de toute façon et ce n'est pas le cas
vraiment te retenir longtemps parce qu'à
le grand mémorial de l'année prochaine à Riga
vous avez remporté un prix brillant très
beaucoup dans l'esprit de Tal et nous regarderons
à cela dans un instant mais d'abord pouvez-vous
dis que UH a fait le jeu de Mil Tal
Vous influencer en tant que jeune joueur parce que
De nombreux jeunes joueurs pointent vers T à cause de
l'excitation de son jeu UH Eh bien de
bien sûr j'ai commencé Les jeux de Tout le Monde
Champions et certainement tous
Ils ont eu une certaine influence sur moi
Mais je ne nommerais pas spécialement T, je veux dire
comme vous pouvez le voir, mon style n'est pas exactement
comme T Style aux échecs et je le ferais
dis que c'est un peu plus proche de Carp Peut-être
en fait, peut-être parce que mon premier livre
échecs quand j'avais cinq ans, mon père a acheté
un livre et c'était un livre sur la carpe de
Les meilleurs jeux et je le fais très attentivement
Il n'y avait pas d'autres livres dans notre petit
Librairie Town Shop donc je n'en avais qu'une
Réservez pendant un an et étudiez-le, vous savez
répéter l'analyse des jeux, puis
Peut-être que cela a eu une grande influence sur moi
Parce que MON STYLE est peut-être plus
positionnel je dirais mais bien sûr je
j'apprécie beaucoup, je veux dire, c'est quelque chose
Génial Qu'est-ce qu'il faisait quelque chose
Génie ok ok Eh bien maintenant, jetons un coup d'oeil
à ce match contre le onzième et voyez comment
Calme et positionnel, c'est vraiment
était
alors ouais, je sais
F3 d5 D4 kn F6 C4 C6 kn C3 E6 Fou G5
D tak C4 Eh bien, c'est un très célèbre
variante Il porte le nom d'un de mes
Les professeurs sont effectivement champion du monde Michel
bwi
UH Qui était aussi un de mes professeurs UH
malheureusement il est décédé plusieurs fois
il y a des années UH et c'est un très Sharp
Variation très forte probablement Mon adversaire
UH Grand maître estonien elfique UH
Espérer que
UH Eh bien, peut-être qu'il me connaissait comme un très
joueur de position et il voulait obtenir
moi Dans les complications Juste pour
m'a dérouté d'une manière ou d'une autre mais j'étais prêt pour
il E4 B5 E5 H6 Bishop H4 G5 je suis dans le
la position est très complexe et je ne le ferai pas
probablement expliquer tous les mouvements ici c'est
selon la théorie, ce sont les meilleurs
Bouge et je crois que c'est vrai Knight
prend G5 H prend G5 Bishop prend
G5 UH Chevalier B
J7
G3 Queen A5 C'est une suite rare
ce qui prouve probablement que mon adversaire
Je voulais simplement confondre avec certains rares
configurer normalement La façon normale de jouer est
Bishop B7 et en fait Cette variation est
tellement intéressant tellement compliqué que beaucoup
les joueurs l'ont apprécié et l'ont utilisé avec les deux
col avec du Noir et du Blanc avec tout à fait
un bon succès Une fois que j'y ai joué avec
Noir contre gpar aussi C'était un match nul donc
La variation est très intéressante et
positions normalement très pointues et
normalement il faut en sacrifier
Matériel pour UH pour gagner le jeu donc E
prend F6 Bishop
A6 approche pas très typique normalement
Les noirs placent leur Fou sur B7 afin de
Contrôlez cette diagonale, c'est El Black
Veut protéger le C4 et ensuite être
prêt à pousser le sien du côté Queen Side
dès que possible donc Queen F3
attaquant Le pa C6 qui doit être
défendu protégé
tour8 Fou
E2 Eh bien, le développe normalement son bish
sur G2 en variations mais maintenant le s'approche
Le et le bish en même temps K E4
Only Move et maintenant C3 est très injouable
pour les blancs parce que l'évêque contrôle
The Square sur la F1 et les Blancs légalement
Je ne peux malheureusement pas châteaur et puis le
le roi au Centre devient très très
faible et les noirs ont un contre-jeu sérieux
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de jouer à Bishop E2
Ce qui est un peu inhabituel mais au moins
Je peux châteaur un jour Bishop E2 B4 Knight
E4
C5
Eh bien, je dirais que pendant le jeu, je
que BL Play n'est pas logique, c'est tout simplement
pas logique, sa peau est au centre
Peut aussi être très faible et il commence
poussant son Ici du côté de la Reine Non
Le développement réel signifie Regardez Bishop sur
F et tour H
UM, donc j'avais le sentiment qu'il devrait y en avoir
quelque chose et puis
Après je pense avoir trouvé un moyen très intéressant
pour jouer, je suis allé D Ici, c'est
édifié par safice
en fait parce que si je prends C, alors laisse
dis que K prend 5, sa reine entre dans le
jeu k prend5 je ne sais pas Queen prend5
suivi de Queen d5 L'idée du d5
bouger, c'est limiter toutes ses pièces, je donne
Mon pion mais son Fou n'est pas
aller n'importe où de F sa reine est sortie
De Play également sur A5 After D et
Attaque directe sur mon adversaire Kin Which
est au centre donc d5 E prend d5 Queen
F5 UH très important Déplacement très important
Bougez UH parce que si je disons si je fais
Short Castle Ouais, c'était une idée
Idée originale pour y jouer mais ensuite Black
il est temps de déplacer son
Queen jouera Queen B6 suivi de Queen
E6 et kn5 et organiser une sorte de
Défense ici que la reine F5 est bien plus
précisément parce que j'attaque le père
d5 Maintenant je suis prêt à le prendre alors D prend
E4 Maintenant, il suffit de châteaur et il n'y a pas de
Force créée ici, je veux dire
Il s'agit simplement d'être une peau noire.
au Centre et maintenant L'alliance est
Open D Line est ouvert alors eine l'est aussi
je vais prendre le pa le plus
probablement pour et puis hisin est der
et
Je me souviens déjà d'avoir regardé les jeux
de T et il le ferait, je sais, je sais avec certitude
il ne renoncerait pas à un tel ordinateur pour
Une telle attaque, je veux dire
donc
ce Castle Now Queen doit prendre M
défendre la tour
C7 défend le fait d'avoir éloigné ses proches
du Centre pour jouer Peut-être k d c8
Plus tard, peut-être même suivi de K B8 et
Après tout, je veux dire, nous ne devrions pas oublier
qu'il a un grand avantage matériel
donc les blancs doivent jouer avec beaucoup d'énergie
Évêque
G4 attaque à nouveau The K et bien je veux
pour libérer la ligne E pour ma tour, donc je veux
jouer la tour Une tour prendre C4 Suivant donc
bisou
B5 Puits
ce n'était pas aussi simple que je l'ai expliqué
Parce qu'il y avait de nombreuses variantes qui
n'étaient pas complètement clairs, je veux dire, c'est
pas comme si les Blancs avaient une vie très facile et
Je gagne l'attaque ici mais je ne veux pas
j'entre dans des complications mais je dois dire
Que j'analyse beaucoup ce jeu euh après
et les Blancs ont toujours assez d'Attaque pour
obtenir un avantage mais ce n'est pas une question de
gagner le jeu, c'est juste un avantage donc
mais bien sûr, la situation est la suivante
compliqué que mon adversaire ait commencé à
entrer dans Time Trouble en réfléchissant beaucoup, je
ça veut dire calculer toutes les lignes et peut-être
sa défense n'était pas aussi obstinée qu'elle
pourrait être donc Bishop B5 Queen prend E4
Vérifiez K d8 et maintenant
très UH très difficile Déménager
psychologiquement Ici, j'ai réussi à trouver
Je veux dire encore une fois, j'ai eu beaucoup de mouvements attrayants
Bishop F4, je veux dire de nombreux mouvements attrayants
mais euh, j'ai passé tout mon temps presque tout mon temps
temps à la recherche d'un peu de Force Win mais je
je n'envisageais pas vraiment un déménagement simple
Bish prend
D7 puis quand j'ai vu ce mouvement parce que tu
voir psychologiquement assez souvent c'est
très difficile d'abandonner un si fort
Bishop sur G4 qui contrôle The
diagonales Pour ce Chevalier sur D4 pour cela
je sais à J7, je veux dire, ce qui est UH en fait
Simplement sur PIN PIN kn ce chevalier ne peut pas
Déplacer et ne pourra pas bouger dans le
Suivant Un futur si psychologiquement Parfois
Les joueurs du CH manquent simplement ça
Se déplace et quand je l'ai trouvé, je
tout calculé et
C'est gagner un coup, il faut 7 coups
prend 7 et la tour
H1 maintenant je ne sais pas si tu vois les trois
la menace est la reine M parce que le
L'évêque est allumé
PIN si si Black passe c8 alors un autre
Mate Reine A8
Copain
c'est ce qu'il a défendu. Comment je veux protéger son
Peau et mais il n'y a rien que tu puisses faire
Parce que Bishop n'a pas de carrés pour
exemple Si vous enlevez ce pa alors
si les Noirs pourront jouer Bishop
C5 Il pourrait aller bien mais il n'y a pas
moyen de défendre
Contre Queen Mate alors il est devenu Bishop
H6 et maintenant tout est forcé Après
Bishop H6 Il y a un joli compagnon en fait
en plusieurs coups, la reine a vérifié c'est
la tour complètement forcée c8 est Only Move
pour protéger le K Maintenant, la tour prend Le
Sept enregistrent Sacrifice mais celui-ci est
c'est déjà beaucoup plus facile et After Ken prend
the7 Queen d5 Check et Here Mon adversaire
a démissionné à cause de la force exercée après
Kin C7 rookie7 Vérifiez UH et maintenant B Kin B6
ou Kin B8 suivi de Queen B7
Mate Ok, c'est un jeu passionnant de
étiez-vous concentré principalement sur
j'étudie en préparant des ouvertures à ce
Pointez ou essayiez-vous toujours de
améliorer votre compréhension globale de
le jeu ou la fin des jeux Où était votre
votre L'accent de votre travail sur ces
années Eh bien, quand j'étais à la maison, la plupart du temps, je
Je travaillais sur des ouvertures parce que bien
c'est un travail très complexe car de nos jours
Lorsque vous travaillez assez souvent sur des ouvertures,
par la force, on arrive à une fin de partie et ainsi
toi toi en même temps tu travailles
sur votre technique de fin de partie aussi mais
UH Quoi Qu'est-ce qui était très important UH Ça
J'ai réalisé en fait dans mes premiers linaires
Quand j'ai joué, j'ai réalisé que le très
l'important c'est juste que j'essayais de ne pas le faire
à Miss UH N'importe quelle autopsie, vous connaissez le
joueurs d'échecs après le jeu, d'accord dans un
Match C'est différent Nous ne le faisons pas
avec G juste peut-être quelques ver mais
normalement dans un tournoi après le match
Les joueurs d'échecs vont analyser
ensemble euh le jeu ça peut durer
Une heure Deux heures Il suffit d'analyser
position Partagez simplement leurs points de vue sur le
Jeu et surtout quand c'était l'un des
le
Playerspp, à cette époque, je rejoignais toujours
cette analyse postm Juste pour voir le chemin
Ils chantent juste juste juste pour voir que c'était
tout d'abord très excitant pour moi
intéressant et aussi je pense que c'était très
utile pour ma compréhension du CH Parce que je
était-ce que je m'asseyais tranquillement quelque part
et regarde-le, juste ouais, c'était à
à ce moment-là, c'était incroyable, je me souviens de mon
première rencontre avec par et première fois que je
je l'ai vu analyser le jeu Après avec
un adversaire et c'était étonnant que tu sois
je sais, je, je ne pouvais pas croire combien
variations qu'il voit pendant un jeu, vous
je sais que j'étais, j'étais juste avec mes bouches UH
Ouvre tu sais assis là et juste
je ne pouvais pas y croire maintenant, il ne semble pas
donc pour moi Non mais mais ce n'est pas parce qu'il
j'ai commencé à en voir moins mais parce que d'accord
Bien sûr, j'improvise le joueur d'échecs et je
voir beaucoup plus maintenant pendant le jeu mais je
rappelez-vous que c'était très utile
une des choses qui était un peu
intéressant à propos de ce match était le
Nature classique des ouvertures jolies
beaucoup dans l'UM par exemple Le
Défense sicilienne qui a été un
visiteur régulier de Match After Match
Après le match, UM, tu n'étais pas obligé de le faire, UH
Recourez à cela ou revenez en arrière.
plusieurs Siciliens que vous évidemment
J'apprécie de jouer avec l'un d'eux, Noir.
la variation classique le Rick der
variation d'éveil et nous allons regarder
à un jeu dans une minute où vous adoptez
Ça devient noir mais y avait-il un
décision de À peu près que le
le sicilien n'allait pas en faire partie
UH, cette expédition, non, ça pourrait être ça
ça pourrait être bien sûr, je veux dire, j'ai préparé
presque toutes les ouvertures possibles. Ici, je veux dire
Le
UH, je pense que j'ai dépensé seulement peut-être 10%
de ma préparation Ici j'ai encore beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à jouer mais euh et bien c'est
juste je veux dire, quand tu joues, c'est très
important dans un match je veux dire quand quand
tu joues une ouverture et c'est vraiment
tout va bien ton adversaire
Je ne peux pas vraiment le casser alors pourquoi pas
Je répète mais bien sûr, je veux dire, je me suis préparé
sicilien et aussi quelques autres ouvertures I
veux dire UH, j'étais prêt à jouer au sicilien si
La situation du match serait différente.
j'étais prêt à jouer différemment, ok, je
Je ne vous demanderai pas quel Sicilien mais nous sommes
je vais regarder maintenant un rior rouser et
Une des choses intéressantes
à propos de ce rior rouser sicilien, c'est toi
retrouve-le dans les jeux des grands maîtres
avec une fréquence assez bonne mais pas d'amateurs
Avez-vous quelque chose à dire sur la raison pour laquelle cela
semble Uniquement pour en Professionnel
Événements Eh bien, je ne sais pas, je ne sais pas
C'est assez étrange de bien en fait
UH, ce n'est pas le sicilien le plus populaire
C'est peut-être l'un des plus classiques
les siciliens mais ce n'est pas le plus populaire
Eh bien maintenant, à cause du
Kasparov le plus populaire est Soced Neer
variation Tout le monde y joue maintenant parce que
Kasparov il l'a développé il a commencé à
j'y ai joué et il a développé beaucoup de ça
C'est comme ça que ça s'ouvre, mais je crois que c'est à peu près
La mode, vous la connaissez, c'est une question de mode
et ce R rusen est R rouser n'est pas un
mauvaise ligne du tout, je veux dire, j'en ai eu beaucoup
victoires convaincantes là-bas Contre très
Les meilleurs joueurs bien sûr One Generation
avant Kasparov Fisher Était aussi un très
Grand Fan du Sicilien et peut-être
peut-être que c'est quelque chose qui vient juste
développé dans la seconde moitié du XXe
Siècle que de plus en plus le
la complexité des Siciliens faisait appel à
les meilleurs joueurs UM mais où au début nous
J'ai vu le dragon sicilien qui est
conceptuellement assez simple Vous mettez votre
Bishop sur G7 et foncez Le rck der
l'éveil est plus subtil UM et donc maintenant
nous allons regarder un jeu que vous
joué contre Robert Hubner à Dortmund
en 1996 qui présente ceci
Ouverture donc et Black E4
C5 Eh bien, je dois dire que Ccilian était à moi
Arme principale, euh, depuis que j'ai sept ans.
vieille et presque la seule arme, je veux dire, je
j'ai joué tellement de CCiliens dans ma vie que
Je pensais qu'il était temps de changer tu sais
Juste pour le plaisir D6 D4 cd4 kn prend D4
Chevalier F6 Chevalier C3 Chevalier
C6 UH Eh bien, c'est une façon de jouer
Une autre façon est de jouer à E6 G6 est
différent et comme G aime jouer
A6 donc je vais C Eh bien l'inconvénient de
toi, chaque mouvement que j'ai montré a
avantage et désavantage désavantage
de C6 c'est que normalement Noir C'est Génial
pour que les Noirs aient le choix entre
Déplacer K sur D7 ou C6 parfois ça reste
Bien sur D7 sur certaines lignes L'avantage
c'est que les noirs n'ont pas toujours besoin
A6 Parfois, on peut enregistrer un Temp avec A6
et aussi noir
J'ai toujours la possibilité de jouer au G6 ou au E
l'un des mouvements l'un des différents ensembles qui
pour pas si facile par exemple Après
Bish jouait beaucoup de G6
Après quelques Move comme Bishop E3 ​​​​je pense que je
joué à l'E5 parfois et après disons
Bishop G5 comme c'était le cas dans ce jeu
est allé
E6 Reine
D2 Eh bien, c'est le plus direct et le plus
Approche dangereuse pour les Blancs
faire un long château le plus normalement
et c'est le plus considéré comme étant
depuis déjà de nombreuses années, peut-être depuis 50 ans
années l'approche la plus dangereuse
Contre ce système A6, enfin, je
fais ça
de toute façon
H6 semble un peu étrange mais a
parce que
c'est assez Un For Parfois F4 alors
À cause de cela dans F E5, ce genre d'ensemble
et les noirs conduisent cet évêque
un moyen pour
E3 et ça continue
H6 c'est très Double à partir d'un Point C'est
arrête le blanc quand le blanc laisse dit F G4 H4
ça l'empêche de ce mouvement G5 forance S
Le noir et le blanc passeraient simplement au G4, au G5, donc
Arrêtez cette attaque mais depuis un autre point
C'est beaucoup plus dangereux maintenant pour Black
au château côté court parce qu'après
H4 G5 Je veux dire, disons ce genre de
position H La ligne H sera ouverte et
le roi l'obtiendra très rapidement donc
Black doit faire attention, je veux dire avec Tel
Déplace Bishop E3 ​​​​mais tout cela n'est que théorie
J'explique juste quelques idées de base mais
en général, voici les
Mouvements théoriques Bishop E7 F4
Va pour différents essais de Set
Outil Les places centrales et mais quand même
si Noir C alors Blanc commencera
définitivement l'attaque du côté Kin donc
noir normalement noir ne devrait pas se dépêcher C
Gardez Ke au centre pendant un moment.
développer des pièces et ensuite voir Quoi Quoi
Les blancs le font. C'est un plan général.
ça prend D4 mais prend D4
B5 en développement bish et aussi Start
pousser
c'est ainsi que l'évêque D3 Parce qu'avant c'était
menacer certaines lignes et When K Goes
loin de mon père, il était si blanc
joue Bishop D Juste pour pouvoir
Contrôler le Centre développer des pièces et
Les blancs sont prêts si disons Black Castle
Les blancs sont prêts à partir. Juste pour aller de l'avant G4
et G5 et c'est très dangereux à prendre
la tour de pion G1 et ça va probablement
être fait tout à fait
bientôt
EUH
c'est pourquoi
B4 B4 UH, c'est normal, ce mouvement n'est pas
tellement génial en sicilien c'est un peu trop
tôt pour ce mouvement, mais le fait est
qu'After Knight E2 Black joue Queen
A5 K B1 et
E5 et du coup C'est un très
manœuvre intéressante Parce que du coup
Vous pouvez regarder le blanc
morceaux Eh bien disons qu'après est allé Bishop3
Maintenant tu peux regarder et soudain tout blanc
morceaux Deux bish et K ne sont pas très
Actif après cet homme, je veux dire, tu vois
le carré avant E5 K ne peut pas aller en D4 ou
C3 kn Ce n'est pas très actif sur Bishop
sur D3 si sinon E5 alors les Blancs ont un
possibilité de jouer à E5 Un jour et de
ouvrez ce Bishop mais maintenant, après E5, c'est
Limité et un autre évêque est limité par
les noirs Ce n'est pas non plus très actif donc
C'est une configuration très intéressante.
cette configuration est que le Square d5 est
Nous
bec
pas foran aussi donc maintenant cle maintenant ce n'est pas le cas
C'est plus dangereux, tout ce G4 parce que
Bishop contrôle cela et Black est également
prêt à commencer à contrer Peut-être même avec
d5 Pour briser le centre, maintenant
ce G4 ATT n'est pas le cas
Dangereux R
H1 essayant
juste pour éviter une sorte de pause en D
et juste pour faire ce genre de Yac Move
tout protéger et puis
en général, l'idée des Blancs n'est pas d'attaquer
immédiatement mais d'abord pour protéger son
Peau puis démarrez lentement l'attaque
et essayez de lutter contre le Push d5
Ce qui est très typique pour ce poste
donc tour
B8 Juste polyvalent Déplacer protégeant Le
mettre en gage avant si ma reine le souhaite
allez aussi, c'est comme vous le verrez plus tard dans
cette tour de jeu pourrait entrer
Attaque R
C1 donc je vais en C1 pour protéger Just in
Boitier pa A2 B2 Juste Juste pour avoir très
Configuration sécurisée Ici et Blanc essaie lentement
pour attaquer le roi
Tour latérale
d8 Black L'idée de Black est de jouer d5 One
Journée donc je fais juste ce genre de
Se déplace ainsi
à un moment donné, quand les blancs commenceront à jouer
Action Ici alors je serai prêt pour
D c'est juste une sorte de aussi
propilactique Déplacer Bishop A7 Eh bien, c'est
un homme blanc typique veut retirer son
Bishop de l'E3 et
UH Peut-être d'une certaine manière, Peut-être qu'il veut
Quelque part pour déplacer sa tour à travers le
SW Run Somewhere pour lancer une attaque
mais touche d'abord ma tour en jouant Bishop
Utilisation du A7, je dois aller au B7 et seulement maintenant
Bishop G1 Juste, je veux dire, ma position de
ma tour serait bien meilleure en B8 donc
ce genre de petit peu ennuyeux
les choses que font vos adversaires de temps en temps
Temps donc Bishop G1 Bishop
G4 mais cette configuration est plus je dirais que je
la configuration moyenne des blancs est plus classique
Parce que Hubner est
UH Joueur classique très connu
et et joueur très positionnel mais en
Général en sicilien Dis que je pense ça
C'est pourquoi j'ai choisi de jouer Sian contre lui
Parce qu'en sian, normalement, c'est beaucoup plus
Dangereux est une appro très directe et ici
déjà j'étais assez content de mon
position Parce qu'il n'y a pas de béton
Danger et normalement je dirais dans un
Un moyen simple : si les Noirs parviennent à
Survivre aux 25 premiers mouvements sans aucun
Dommage à la Sicilienne puis Plus tard c'est
tout ira bien normalement, alors voici Bishop
G4 attaquant La tour Il n'y a pas de carré
pour cette tour donc B3 doit jouer pour
Attaquez la Reine puis obtenez ce C1
Reine carrée
A4 Bon carré pas très typique pour le
Queen normalement, Queen irait en C7 mais
Queen A4 parce que j'avais déjà l'idée
dans ma tête
C1 Maintenant, comme vous pouvez le voir, les Blancs veulent
jouez F5 puis My Bishop sur G4 est dedans
Danger suivi de quelque chose comme ça
Je prends cet évêque donc je dois l'assumer
F4 il prend4 Reine prend Fou
E6 et bien Bishop D4 avec qui il repart
son évêque active son évêque une fois le
le pion a disparu de l'E5 Blanc
essaie définitivement d'utiliser ce D4 Square
pour son évêque mais le prochain
move J'ai été une surprise pour mon adversaire
Ce n'est pas une démarche très typique pour
cilian mais très fort où je suis allé
tour B5
Ici c'est très intéressant
Bougez bien, cela ressemble à une erreur
Parce que White Simply peut affronter B5 mais
si les Blancs le font alors a prend B5 et je
réussi à ouvrir le très important un
La ligne de course blanche est Exchange Up What
ce serait normalement suffisant pour gagner mais en
Cette situation particulière rook8 est un
menace et les noirs commencent très fort
Attaque contre le roi
les choses sont donc assez critiques pour
Blanc là-bas. Eh bien, je pense qu'il y en avait
pour défendre mieux que lui
mais il est devenu Queen D2 maintenant ouais et bien je
Une autre chose est
qu'en fait je menace de jouer au tour
A5 Maintenant on attaque sur A2 et si kn prend
A5 alors comme vous pouvez le voir, Queen prend A2
Mat donc tour B5 L'idée est de jouer
en fait, c'est pourquoi j'ai mis ma reine sur A4
bien sûr, j'avais déjà ça en tête
genre d'idée alors il est devenu reine
D2 avec sorte de Petit Piège I le Point
est si je vais R5 maintenant encore prendre A5 est
Impossible mais alors A3 je pense que c'est le cas
possible et disons que B prend A3 maintenant
il peut déjà affronter A5 avec une Reine
c'est pourquoi il est allé Queen D2 pour attaquer le
tour Dans cette variante Dans cette variante
Mais je n'ai pas besoin de me dépêcher et je saute
commence à sauter d'un autre côté
G4 donc comme vous pouvez le voir sian très typique
Jeu Blacks to Jump, je veux jouer à Bish
G de ce H est H Passer par E5 jusqu'à C4
et je pense que Robert H a commencé à
loseol sur cette position La position est
ça ne plaît plus à White mais il en quelque sorte
il a perdu le contrôle et il s'est effondré dans un
il a fait quelques mouvements
C4 B prendre C3 C4 n'est pas un bon mouvement de
Bien sûr, parce que ça m'ouvre quelques lignes
et UH Maintenant, il a réalisé que je pense qu'il était
il voulait prendre avec C mais ce n'était pas le cas
bon à cause de la tour A5 ou du fou G5 maintenant
il s'en est rendu compte et il est allé B prend C3
Ce qui est bien sûr déjà un peu UH
démission parce que maintenant très simple Mo
la tour prend B3 juste en ouvrant les lignes a
prend B3 Bishop prend B3 et Blanc est
Changez mais sa position est complètement
le prochain coup des noirs détruits est la tour B8
et simplement fabriqué du côté de la reine et
c'est pourquoi il
d'accord, démissionné, cela nous amène vers le haut
jusqu'en 1996 et nous prenons
Une autre pause et ensuite nous finirons UH
Se rapprocher un peu du présent UH
nous répondrons à quelques questions du
public à ce moment-là donc pendant ce
Pause Tu peux réfléchir Si tu as quelque chose
à UH pour demander au nouveau champion du monde
UH, prépare tes questions, nous le ferons quand même
Regardez quelques jeux supplémentaires et nous allons
Rendez-vous dans 15 minutes Merci
[applaudissements]
toi